djamel donc d'être au bataclan à partir
du 15 septembre
est ce que c'est le même spectacle et
récits galles on a repris la base du
premier spectacle qui nous paraissait
pas inintéressante manga lui tellement
de succès on a retravaillé autour et on
a trouvé des choses un peu en fin d'été
où il ya des nouvelles choses bien sûr
j'aurais pu répondre par oui j'ai fait
une question assez long mais c'est ça
fait traiter les lapereaux l'interview
vous aimez les chiens jamais joué dans
les chiens très bien alors le sait le
même metteur en scène oui kader aoun
vous pensez durer jusqu'à noël
si tout se passe bien plus court si tout
se passe bien jusqu'à noël
ouais si linda viens pour me soutenir
bensalah on sera là la personne alors
djamel on s'est connu tous les deux il
ya quand même quelques années maintenant
35 ans d'une lente cinq ans bien sûr une
émission que je faisais à l'époque sur
sur paris dernière sur paris première et
10 à paris dernière tu as fait un numéro
qui était bien d'ailleurs je crois que
c'est votre deuxième télé la première
citée pêche d'enfer c'était la vraie
richesse et un truc comme ça c'était
tout et il est tout près par bus et
édition de plus non si vous avez les
images savoir bien pourquoi c'est pas
bien si les images vous avez toujours à
la télé on invite des gens leur manque
des images que les mettre mal à l'aise
certes il te plait magnéto 6 6 1 jeudi
soir et un marmaille là je suis à si tu
me prends la tête quand le journaliste
tous les jeunes toute manière ils
arrivent ils arrêtent là avec leur leur
technique leur marathon se bricole leurs
questions c'est la fin j'ai croisé
journalistes un mec bizarre joint
ti-jean re6 genre sous un toit genre si
genre tu sens bizarre quand genre
terrorisme genre comme la paille ce
prix-là récit commence à me poser des
questions sur le toit était si petite
fille bizarre si jamais par twente
immeuble était bien habillé de soin de
moi je vais pas je te l'été a été chaud
comme ça comme ça n'a rien fait comme ça
coûte bonbon oxygène
moi aussi je veux être capable je suis
la banlieue comme vous s'ils battent en
mer - écoutez j'ai pas par quatre
chemins je vais quant aux bus en coton à
la question je vais vous parler en toute
franchise de vos problèmes économiques
sociaux culturels car je sais c'est pas
la peine de me dire que vous avez
d'énormes problèmes vous insérez parmi
les gens normaux sains
je sais que votre perte à bodmer et que
vous en est réduit à vous servir de
crédit comme moyen de locomotion surtout
vague soit vrai j'ai des preuves si ça
va chauffer grave j'étais binaire graves
comme lui est tout sauf grave tout à
l'heure après j'ai regardé jeudi le pont
tauzin le brontosaure d'abord duch on
vous voit on n'a jamais voulu d'un cas
l'ensemble que je sache
d'accord la donc tu vois d'abord du
jeudi je me demande quelle est celle où
desquelles plus de mal à s'insérer par
les gendarmes en moi avec mes caddie ou
lui avec sa pub sur la tête là nous deux
c'est pas mon père qui tape ma mère
c'est ma mère car mon père c'était
c'était quand j'étais en cm2 ça ouais
ouais c'est à dire que c'était un très
très longtemps
je me souviens de cette émission non
seulement ça vous embête de non non pas
du tout mais à la télé moi où je me
regarde pas
j'ai toujours un peu critique sur ce que
je fais je fais les choses et souvent je
le trouve pas bien après et là je trouve
ça après bien être du tout au long du
channel à ce qu'on vient de voir donc
c'était la 2e i télé après on pas
raconter votre carrière parce qu'elle a
été racontée en long et en large et une
ovale paris première une autre émission
qui étaient les missions de nova sur
paris première il ya eu il ya eu h
npa le cinéma avec son 11e et puis le
ciel les oiseaux et ta mère quelque
10000 1 million par an 10 millions d'un
million 10 millions d'indiens
il ya des millions de millions mais mnp
à canal+ c'est c1 halabi un alibi pour
vous celle inverse c'est une des fonds
j'ai vu dans les interviews de vous
demander souvent est ce que vous pensez
pas être l'alibi de canal+ moi j'ai
plutôt l'impression finalement c'est
canal+ que votre alibi pour regrouper
durant pour regarder canal plus
uniquement et simplement pour l'argent
faut pas l'oublier et les meufs et ça
marche ça a marché
non mais mes sous pour prendre pour
répondre à tant de plus sérieux on m'a
souvent posé la question il ne faut pas
que tu es là tel a été le quota de
canal+ se prête à un robot de canal+ je
pense vraiment pas je pense que alain de
greef m'a engagé parce qu'il croyait en
moi j'espère enfin je suis sûre même
puisque je le dis comme ça mais c'est un
échange de bons procédés finalement oui
de toute manière comme dans toute
association qui fonctionne bien tu vois
gj gagner et aussi mais c'est sûr qu'au
début on pouvait se poser la question
et enfin continent est en fin de contrat
j'aime ça veut dire à chaque fois qu'il
va pêcher un bouton vous aller applaudir
comme des imbéciles
j'ai compris le système a bien envoyé
une punition aussi dans le sampler si
par exemple vous êtes un truc vraiment
ou moi ou linda bien un truc vraiment
pénible à la punition mesdames et
messieurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on peut faire attention à ce qu'on dit
c'est i muvrini voilà moi je vais pas
intérieure en corse parce que tu vois
non mais mais mais alors chaque fois que
je dirais une connerie ira ça ira ça
ouais et quand tu es quand tu dis un
truc génial au rsa bon alors la gloire
vous dis pas les beaucoup de votre
gloire
la mercedes tapis rouge aux bains
douches etc et j'en parle pas moi sans
légende ils ont fait parler oui oui mais
vous avez quand même il ya un truc plus
intéressant si vous êtes quand même une
méfiance paris vous appelez ça le côté
obscur c'est quand même une méfiance de
paris 1le que ces essais mais c'est vrai
j'ai j'habite à trappes dans les
yvelines et on débarque dans un dans une
jungle véritablement je suis pas là à
faire tu sais très bien comment ça se
passe si harry fait pas ton petit malin
mais je sais mais mais mais ouais j'ai
tout était inaccessible et d'un coup
tout s'ouvre donc forcément tu te mets
fini tu prenais la distance avec les
filles ça se passe bien maintenant un
peu mieux
un peu mieux mais je galère encore
vraiment
[Musique]
ça tombe charrette parce que sinon j'ai
passé la soirée big sound
si aujourd'hui une fille une jeune femme
que vous avez draguer ya cinq ans et qui
vous avez jeté drague à son tour
aujourd'hui je n'achète plus aucun
intérêt
non non il faut passer non je passe à
autre chose maintenant maintenant ccc
linda que juif non des choses qu'il ya
une souris que prendra ta question oui
j'ai fait comment les filles intéressées
non mais je sais pas si je détecte les
filles intéressées moi je suis
sincèrement je suis très naïve de ce
côté là je prends pas encore détecté
quoi que ce soit mais qu'elle
s'intéresse à moi je fonce au but les
moines à la blague à part mais j'ai aimé
c'est vrai que que non j'ai pas j'avais
toujours à trappes j'ai pas bougé je
rencontre les filles avec qui chante
j'avais quand même moins en moins
souvent à trappes
j'habite encore là bas j'y vais tous les
soirs à trouver celui ans plus tard pour
passer oui forcément
alors il ya une phrase moi de vous déjà
m que je trouve très très bien c'est
quand vous parlez de paris vous dites
c'est comme dans le film quand charlton
heston descend du mont sinaï où il a
reçu les dix commandements on vous dit à
moïse un bruit charlton heston
comme ce qui est très symbolique quand
il a reçu les dix commandements il
descend comme ça du il descend du sinaï
voit tous les hébreux en train d'adorer
le veau d'or et ça c'est un peu l'image
que vous faites de paris finalement ben
ouais parce que
sincèrement j'arrive là depuis deux
trois ans dans un univers que je
connaissais pas c'est à dire on se
faisait de recaler matin midi et soir
dans toutes les boîtes vous toutes les
boîtes que j'ai fait sans exception sans
exception je vous dis je me faisais
recalé en bloc tout papa toutes les
filles sans exception mais on avait du
mal avec les filles aussi pareil on
n'avait pas l'argent qu'il fallait pour
avoir les sabres qu'il fallait on
n'était pas dans le coup donc ont été
mis à l'écart et est maintenant d'un
coup tout le monde s'intéresse à moi et
toute votre attention à ce que je dis
c'est formidable alors john l on va
maintenant finir un petit peu cette
parce qu'après on va passer une vrai
interview on va finir un peu avec un
extrait moi qui m'a beaucoup plus c'est
quand vous étiez à cannes c'est
d'ailleurs comme l'émission paris
dernière réalisée par sylvain bergère
c'est le journal de la nuit et on vous
voit face à face avec le plus grand
comique français laurent gerra magnéto
serge s'il te plaît super bowl n'ont pas
profité il y avait là me désabonner plus
long du monde
enfin pas non si si si si c'est drôle
effectivement on a va être pas cette
manière
[Rires]
j'ai bien dis donc qu'est ce qui m'a pas
parce que j'ai c'est qu'on peut pas
bouffer 5e caméra allez encore le cadre
est serré avec un décor à dennis blair
limitation de gêne à l'idée au parlement
face à un sénat en fin de repas selo
demander l'asile à dire qu'il était l'un
des mecs les plus drôles de france voilà
ça c'est vrai
c'est bien changé et est souvent bien
accompagné il dit dans des endroits sion
que c'est la casse mais après tout le
monde circule
ouais c'est l'homme le plus drôle de
france
bon on enchaîne ce copieux alors donc
vous avez comme je disais tout à l'heure
vous avez beaucoup raconté votre légende
vous avez un discours très au point
d'ailleurs qu'on voit à la télé ou quand
on voit ton livre déclarations dans la
presse discours très haut point c'est
parce qu'on pose tout le temps les mêmes
questions c'est justement ce qu'on va
tourner parce que vous dites que vous
avez un personnage très très construit
vous dit évidemment mon personnage est
construite toute pièce parce que si
j'étais comme lui j'aurai une chambre à
sainte anne depuis depuis longtemps bien
évidemment bien évidemment alors à vous
poser des questions qu'on n'a pas
l'habitude de vous poser la télé à ça ça
fait plaisir par contre voilà quoi
respect c'est un peu la lumière
[Musique]
j'aime pas les traquenards comme ça
uncanny x un couteau suisse est possible
ou pas à régis d'enfoirés vous êtes tous
avec lui dans l'éducation simple à vous
pensez à quoi là maintenant tout de
suite tout de suite non c'est non mais
franchement un nom assez vulgairement
non mais tout est en rapport avec toi
vite à ce que des noms mais c'est bon on
peut se lâcher un peu plus nous mêmes
non non je te jure bon je rigole
28la comme ça je me demande ce que tu as
posé comme question
bon ben voilà donc qu'est ce que tu
penses ce matin quand tu te fais dans la
glace quand tu travailles la première
chose que tu te dis quant à vous vous
dites pardon quand vous voyez je me dis
[ __ ] si je faisais dix centimètres de
plus cher et mannequin
c'est pas impossible dix centimètres de
plus bon je serai clyde en scène quand
vous étiez petit millier ressembler à
qui quand j'étais petit je voulais
ressembler à tony montana dans scarface
1 s'est excusé moi ça vu le film
scarface
ouais bien sûr je vous laisse lui comme
plein de mecs dans le quartier ce qu'est
ce qui vous énerve le plus chez vous ce
que je supporte pas c'est difficile ces
jours dans cette question bah ouais mon
moment que 2 des subjectivités je pense
ouais j'aime pas ma subjectivité sauf
qu'elle n'est pas assez adéquat que des
mots compliqués la subjectivité année où
là j'avais dû tabulaire est-ce que vous
supportez pas chez moi qu'est-ce que
vous supportez pas chez moi thierry suc
temps pourquoi tu t'habilles tout le
temps noir pour être sûr qu'on me
reconnaisse non mais c'est pas pour ça
arrête de me dire si c'est pourquoi pas
en tire donc ça ce que ça marche c'est
parce que sa belle fille c'est parce que
sa main si oui bien sûr c'est qu'à un
gros là bas non non non on fait du sport
depuis quelques temps bagéens
connaissent à mal le noir ça m'a simba
le noir c'est nacewa sûr bien sûr la
preuve qu est-ce que vous supportez pas
chez linda ouais j'ai vraiment pour
l'instant rien du tout je supporte tout
pour le moment
quand l'allemagne rêve quand vous êtes
vous senti le maître du monde est ce
qu'un jour vous avez le sentiment d'être
vraiment un demi-dieu de en toute
modestie jamais ouais non non je te jure
que jamais et aujourd'hui ce qu' il ya
quelque chose que vous soyez à voir
absolument
que voudriez par dessus tout vous ne
pouvez pas acheter qui vous tenterait ou
qui vous ferait extrêmement plaisir et
que vous pouvez pas posséder la cas de
fuite comme ça mais il les a parfois
linda je vois pas
je cherche mais non non quelle insulte
qui vous a fait le plus mal en fait dans
votre vie espèce de sale arabe
ouais enfin que m'a fait plus mal c'est
des trucs que je supporte pas du tout
que j'entende de moins en moins
maintenant mais dur mais mais mais c'est
vraiment il par roland attendre et comme
quand vous écrivez eu l'autographe vous
écrivez ça dépend si c'est des filles ou
des garçons est déjà si c'est une fille
de marc gros bisous jamais de nous y
fait un coeur si c'est un garçon je
marque que dégage de booth a dégagé est
ce que vous êtes déjà sortie avec la
copine d'un copain pour voir si vous
avez un peu de moral quand même oui tu
veux tu écris dans le plat là c'est
d'actualité merde merde
non pas du tout jamais je suis avec le
copain ou une copine avec le copain
d'une copine dont calvin non encore
moins bon si par exemple vous trouvez un
porte monnaie que 500 francs dedans par
terre on fait quoi maintenant je leur en
avons voulu garder
ouais c'est bien c'est honnête comme à
nos jours moi je laurent parce que je
pense à la pauvre vieille exemple
j'étais en turquie et je trouve et
s'était hissé tgt j'avais pas encore
autant d'argent qu'aujourd'hui et je
trouve un portefeuille mais super blindé
d'argent plein et épais tousser et et
c'était une demoiselle qui étaient là
qui est qui qui travaillait dans l'hôtel
où j'étais j'ai elle va elle vendait des
pellicules je me rappelle je prends le
portage il jure en jurant pas durant je
rends paris je rentre en page orange
durant pas j'y allais à les jugeant
urgent iv juin et je fais la clé pour
lui rendre sur la queue pour lui rendre
est un moment donné je te jure et juge
alors j'arrive jurant le portefeuille
et puis je lui dit excusez moi je
pourrais avoir cette pellicule mais je
veux faire la queue comme tout le monde
les regarde comme ça dit mais pourquoi
bordel de merde
voilà cela déjà ça m'a énervé qu'est ce
que vous seriez prêt à tout quitter pour
le grand amour ça ça se discute cellule
mais avant ça c'est parce que tu peux
rien faire d'autre moitié je peux pas le
nippon bienvenue canisius peut pas
bluffer habitants du matin il finira 17
heures mais pour elle
peut-être ah si vraiment c'est le grand
amour en grand amour grands quant à moi
je lâche tout donc le grand amour né
n'est pas encore arrivé jamais elle un
héros un héros c'est jamal est ce que si
vous étiez ruiné plus du tout d'argent
fin vraiment plus une thune est ce que
vous seriez prêt à tourner dans un film
porno aucune chance point très simple
jamais je serai je serai ruiné j'étire
on a eu une famille assez solidaires et
dès qu'il ya un problème ils sont là ce
n'est jamais obligé je suis un mais je
pense est-ce que vous préféreriez faire
l'amour avec une fille très laide ou un
mec très beau confie quelques questions
mais que ouais c'est ça faut pas arrêter
comment ces questions alors c'est toi
qui écris les questions comme je ne sais
pas d'idée sur le contrôle des questions
comme toi si tu veux les faux-pas info
prendre dit doliprane parce qu'il ya la
douleur faut stopper la douleur d'abord
fait pour toi maman c'est bien ça stoppe
la douleur etc etc et tu préfère faire
leurs méthodes
une façon c'est où l'homosexualité ou
une fille très nets par an soit une
fille très laide ou un mec très beau
vous choisiriez quoi j'irai plus vers la
savonnette mois et entre une miss monde
les trois miss france ou poêlée quoi bon
je prends trois miss france 3 me seront
utiles pour ces gentils pour les 10 à 20
points 3 miss france si vous aviez 24
heures avis vous feriez quoi on vous dit
vous allez mourir dans 24 heures foyer
quoi il veut au près et fleur bleue tout
ce que tu veux mais c'est la vérité je
vais auprès de maman ouais je reste avec
l 24 heures ils attendent comme sarko
s'agit la douche pas voulu monter jamais
à votre maman non c'est l'une des rares
personnes à qui je mens pas pourquoi
parce que le sait tout de suite quand je
vois pas ce que je fais des petits quand
je mangeais chaque ligne un peu
maintenant je dois je vais y travailler
ah ouais fout de ma gueule
alors y'a un truc chez vous qui est qui
est tristement parce que aujourd'hui
dans l'est la télé à la radio les gens
osent plus dire qu'ils sont croyants
catholiques c'est un peu passé de mode
c'est un peu ringard c'est les gens
comme vous et c'est des gens comme vous
qui osez dire finalement beaucoup plus
que les catholiques
ben moi je suis musulman je suis croyant
également je fais un petit peu des c
c'est d'autant plus difficile qu'en ce
moment on n'a pas trop la cote de ce
côté là les intégristes ne font pas une
super bonne publicité
1 nous non plus les cathos les intégrés
s'ils ne font pas une bonne oui mais
mais mais mais on parle un peu plus de
nous que vous en ce moment - excuses -
excusez moi mais c'est vrai que non j'ai
aucun problème avec ça j'ai été baigné
là dedans
mes parents moi mon moins élevé avec
avec ses traditions là je suis musulman
je l'assumé mais c'est un truc que je
vais très bien parce que l'islam est une
religion qui est très très tolérant très
ouverte et et je la kiffe je trouve que
c'est prêt c'est là c'est la classe
d'être musulman est ce que vous buvez
pas vous fumez pas d'enjeu boit pas elle
fume pas c'est sérieux des gens vous
pratiquez les cinq prières par jour par
exemple j'essaye du mieux que je peux
mais comme je rentre tard des fois c'est
maintenant c'était quand la dernière la
ct garage était le mois de novembre
dernier un vrai dans leurs prières dans
la lah c'était ce matin
ah oui donc 5 c'était entre 8 et 9,9 et
5,1 ce matin je me suis levé et est 10
heures et tu cèdes à des heures précises
avec les fonctionnaires et la demande la
dernière à la dernière c'était ce matin
alors j'en ai encore quatre à rattraper
c'est bien ce que l'on m'a l'air d'être
très très vif carneiro quoi moi ouais je
viens courbet ah non non au nom si je
devrais incarne quelque chose ce sera
endigué par un guépard c'est bien que
j'aie part c'est bien facile avec la
classe le guépard dans la savane il est
bien habillé le guépard il ya des vos
avis est-ce que vous avez menti depuis
le début de cette émission n'ont
franchement pas répondre à ce jour non
pas encore mais c'est bien je suis ravie
mercier c'était le gars de lumière
[Musique]
avant avant de passer à l'autre invité
souvent mais bien entendu vous restez
avec nous je voudrais pardon vous lisez
le championnat ça moi je voulais dire
que j'ai été agréablement surpris par ce
genre de question parce que je suis pas
l'habitude comme les pauses voilà c'est
bien thierry cain d'aiguillon alors
alors avant de costil qu'un mec bien je
me comprends voilà a commencé avec un
petit email de rim qui habite en tunisie
et qui me dit j'ai 21 ans je suis
tunisienne
j'adore ton émission ça serait bien si
vous invitiez jamel debbouze il est bas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand même bon soir à léo lunardi ne
garder que j'aime bien physiquement tu
es mais je préfère lui n'a renié cette
kita bio ce moment ces dépôts
tintinesque américaine d'accord que j'ai
trouvés par terre dans sur une rue
américaine qui s'appelle kissinger teddy
mister jo ouais pourquoi les premières
la veste mais qu'est ce qui se passe
dans cette émission j'ai l'impression
que ma veste a jeté un coup de froid
si vous voulez je peux mettre un autre
gars si ça vous dérange pas c'est à
jamel c'est que la casquette et un peu
de travers non mais je vais t'expliquer
comme je vois que tu es habillée comme
ça depuis 1964
tu sais pas
mais je n'ai pas bien la mode et aussi
parce que dehors il se passe des trucs
incroyables ah bon jamais sorti le temps
des missions des doors tu sais qu'on a
gagné la coupe du monde ou à l'économie
[Musique]
c'est le style c'est le style des states
adacore oui c'est à la mode en ce moment
djamel au cinéma on vous a vu dans l'un
des plus gros cartons de l'année
directement un le fabuleux destin
d'amélie poulain exactement et on va
vous voir dans l'un des plus gros
cartons de l'année prochaine qui
s'appelle mission cléopâtre c'est le
nouvel astérix réalisé par alain chabat
et j'ai fait un numéro bis exactement
j'ai fait je l'aï fait que des cartons
même temps mais merci quand même pour sa
main pour sa vie effet les cartons je ne
sais pas les blacks arrêter sinon je
commencé à insulter les maires il avait
bien fait mais c'est me connais vous
connaissez pas à la mode il ya des trucs
incroyables disent pas cela dans les
rues comment ils s'en foutent et
ailleurs il faut que vous font foi les
faut sortir dans les magasins je suis
arrivé trop tard c'est quoi les magasins
c'est le surplus du cirque barnum
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup monsieur fait plaisir
parce que j'avais pas quoi et quand dire
à un moment donné j'ai sauvé par
balladur
bon alors djamel au tuba ou pas ou n'en
discutait continuer je veux juste voir
tirer en jaune ça m'amuse qu'on aura
est ce que ça fait
c'est entre bad a coûté ce qu'on a vu
clair on a vite passé avec sa voiture et
demandé un mcdo oui ça donne envie de
changer d'air au mcdrive bien de la
garde non mais là pour voir toi s'est
défoulé le tournant du ton actuel avait
aucune aucune sensibilité artistique
fashion ma faute de ne pas faire la
promo l'a26
ouais alors lancé une collection de
fringues non pas dans les cinq films
pour you never soul music et on va
creuser des trous de passer derrière la
caméra il a d'un coup tu étais je
commande des genres coin un verre d'eau
tislit comment ce genre de phrase que tu
peux lancer tout le monde trouve ça
normal c'était vraiment un truc à faire
et puis à la casse est exact danser à la
casse est c'est le très très bien de
djamel jamais vu une cassette pareil des
actions sera jamais
[Applaudissements]
café addison is et je vois que c'est un
vrai public de télévision regarde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est ça la télé moderne bienvenue à
sainte-anne attend donc la première
vidéo jamel en scène quatre cent mille
exemplaires 400 kg ça fait plaisir mais
personne ne s'attendait à un tel c'est
un carton à key west et moi ça va c'est
bien c'est cool alors le très très bien
de djamel donc c'est chez canal + vidéo
et ça coûte 99 francs
comme le livre de frédéric beigbeder qui
avaient énormément de succès ouais
peut-être que ça va vous aider en même
temps peut-être que ça va l'aider si
jamais on ne sait jamais ça peut
relancer le fait pour nous alors c'est
une sélection concoctée par le génial
kader aoun
c'est moi qu'on puisse dire c'est lui
qui fait tout en fait non il fait pas
tout s'amuse bien ensemble tous les deux
ma mère va à faire des choses qui nous
amuser web des croissants dans quelque
part c'est drôle en général il est fort
il est passé par des chinois que j'ai
pas et j'ai pas eu un point que j'ai pas
eu de la chance d'emprunter à savoir aux
sciences po par contre il a fait
sciences po lille a fait sciences po oui
monsieur il habite toujours à bobigny
dans le 93 comme quoi c'est possible
merde donc c'est le meilleur moment de
jamel dans les années canal mal et
auxerre bonjour salut c'est cool je me
présente je m'appelle dequevy aussi
steven oui c'est super voix sarladaise
n'importe quoi c'est pas vrai que les
arabes je ne sais pas quoi on avait dit
ça ya six ans déjà quand j'étais petit
je me disais ça va bien rasé j'ai dit
oui la saison mais des savoirs bien
varié je veux dire non et comment c'est
pas toi sinon je veux dire trop
d'histoires
regardez là bas qu'elle avait quittés
les données du bien
bonjour on connaissait six mois en berne
en ligne et vous bernard henri lévy bhl
pondu bhl comme ça ça va beaucoup plus
vite
là on en a flat montparnasse et depuis
bientôt deux heures de dédicaces mon
nouveau livre une vie un chien en doute
tu as peut-être ça va bien de wassup
salamin dépend bien sûr du chantier
cucchi la baisse il à la baisse
ça va bien très bien à bien ses travaux
un décor très bien
[Applaudissements]
l'appel à kadhafi de m
[Musique]
messier sais pas michel comment
s'appelle alors cette humanité que
mâcher une très compliqué ça s'appelle
la part de faire la barbe touffue
oui lui la barre de fer qu à la barre du
fear to la barre de fer dissidia sous la
barre des arts est mon mec tu me saoules
l'art ça monsieur madame karembeu compta
fils comme ça qu'on met s'appelle 6 x 7
ce qui se voit cette 42e
bonjour vous reconnaissez chez jean paul
gaultier fait qu terreur un as parce que
je suis habillé comme à guam c'est pour
ça que vous connaissez pas mais
qu'est-ce qui fait frétiller mais
l'oreille de la sarthe ne serait ce donc
pas des gaz ou devant des demoiselles
qui proviennent du bas de la colline
mais oui bon duc des lombards que votre
vision est juste et acer il est vraiment
mon balai mais l'amour a ses raisons que
les limites ne connaissent pas les
vraies raisons de son amour tu comprends
jamais rien quand je m'escrime et ouais
tu avais je détale contre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tél
le moment est bond james bond je
travaille au service de la reine
elizabeth 4 plus de montants bâton et
deux pouces jamais de boost qui
travaille au service de pizza pino
allait très bien
aucun set
en dvd
non
c'est non ces gars là mais il faut tout
cela j'étais là c'est énorme ça fait
plaisir c'est sur la chaîne qui avait
avant là comment elle s'appelait la
chaîne la gamme al oula laquelle mémoire
c'est à dire seulement tuer tuer les
gens et tu t'éclates parce que ta tête
un dessin un destin incroyable
maintenant tu chantes anne marie white
et comme on dit chez moi
non c'est une honte il faut qu'on menait
de djamel ont fait un jamel ton
[Applaudissements]
non c'est là s'il vous plaît j'ai besoin
de chanel on va parler maintenant de le
sujet un petit peu plus sérieux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on va commencer par parler de la police
la police plein de dommages et contrer
quand vous avez je n'avais pas compris
le show et quand j'ai vu le mec comme ça
donnez moi ça vous a rappelé des
souvenirs alors c'est marrant quand même
jamel parce que finalement il ya joey
starr béatrice dalle samy naceri arthur
nagui larusso arthur m6 solar faudel
palmade puff daddy très souvent la
presse se fait l'écho de deux stars qui
pète un peu les plombs comme ça devant
les flics ou à bercy par exemple
histoire je souris logiciel qu'est ce
qui se passe vous a laissé le 1er
janvier 2000 nous sommes encore en sort
les deux sièges qui se comprend bien
la décote qui vont tourner merde vous
sortez du parking de bercy dans votre
mercedes 4 4 vous mettez dans un convoi
de gendarmes mobiles qu'est-ce qui se
passe ouais jg il ya eu peut-être un
malentendu de la part de tout le monde
mais mais moins la mienne en tout cas ça
c'est sûr gg j'ai malencontreusement
sans l'avoir vu je suis entré dans un
combat de police effectivement et puis
déjà c'est drôle le dernier dans vos
fichiers jamais c'est drôle mais crois
moi surtout ce que j'ai de plus cher au
monde que j'ai vraiment je suis rentré
je suis entré dans cette voie et est
quoi cette m plus tard je ne suis pas
arrêtée par rapport à par deux motards
qui m'ont demandé de mettre sur ma côté
et et j'ai fait ce qu'ils m'ont demandé
de faire la première fois et puis il a
été un peu plus un peu plus virulent me
demandant de mettre plus sur le bas-côté
g
j'ai celle de mettre encore plus sur le
bas-côté donc le moment il ya plus de
variété tu peux plus aller sur mon côté
j'ai baissé ma vie 30 janvier puis le
plus beau côté comment on fait et hélas
il a été allumée qui s'est pas marc et
moi je moi j'aurais djamel tu fais ça je
me marrais même si j'étais j'ai pas
exactement dix ans je me suis mis dîner
en fils de [ __ ]
comment ça je veux mettre sur le bas
côté non vraiment ici y'a pas eu des
mots échangés bonjour fait des supers
signe j'ai fait loin des grands signes
pour aller vers la droite aussi et quand
j'ai baissé ma vitre en disant qu'il n'y
avait plus moyen de la droite et il sait
il s'est énervé il avait garé sa voiture
et puis là il m'a sorti de la voiture
comme si j'avais comme si j'ai jamais vu
j'avais fait entrer un avion de ligne
sur la tenue de terreur là il a été très
virulent il est essentiel et puis et
puis et puis et puis c'est partir en
cacahuète mais cela qui vous a fait une
clé de bras et qui avait fait la une
dans le ventre ouais ils ont été
entassées assez violent à ce moment là
moi comme je t'écoute ma famille
forcément ça il ya eu il ya eu un
affrontement
même mes frères mes frères étaient là je
fais une clé de bras je sais c'était
assez délicat quand j'étais c'était
vraiment c'était vraiment violent de
quoi comme truquées jeu c'était dur moi
j'ai subi une injustice mois qu'on en
dise j'ai perdu mon procès je fais appel
tout n'a pas été fait dans je suis sûr
qu'on a oublié plein de choses et je
vais je vais le démontrer mais mais je
crois en la justice de ce pays et puis
je sais qu'on me rende justice quoi
qu'il arrive parce que je suis une
victime
je suis victime dans cette histoire
maintenant je me suis jamais prononcée
parce que mes avocats on pensait que
c'était pas mal comme ça j'aime bien
mais quand on pensait qu'il n'allait pas
se prononcer à ce moment là parce que
parce que c'est sacré sariska danville
d'envenimer les choses et et de porter
préjudice préjudice est cette chose que
j'ai suivi leurs conseils je regrette
amèrement aujourd'hui parce que
effectivement quoi qu'on fasse on est
perdant tu vois jusqu'à ce que je peux
ce que je trouve horrible dans ce [ __ ]
de système c'est que j'arrive avec 45
minutes de retard à un repas et puis
j'explique que je viens de faire
contrôler par la police vers 5h45 là on
passe aux desserts comme si de rien
n'était pas donc finalement c'est normal
mais c'est après tout on trouve aussi
après tout le monde trouve ça normal
pourquoi pas moi c'est bien normal du
droit mais bien on va passer un deuxième
sujet grave
l'islam oui pourquoi ces graves l'islam
ben c'est grave parce que les gens
confondent arabe et musulman déjà et
tous les arabes ne sont pas musulmans il
y en a qui sont catholiques y en a qui
sont juifs et puis ensuite musulmans on
confond aussi souvent avec islamistes et
on peut être musulman sans être
islamistes et avec ce qui s'est passé
cette semaine à new york on est inquiet
de voir une espèce d'amalgamé comme ça
et de devoirs démarre en france une
espèce de racisme anti arabe alors que
la plupart des arabes et des musulmans
va réprouvent ce qui s'est passé à new
york il ya un avion qui rentre dans la
plus grande tour du monde c'est
irrationnel quoi tu vois quand quand
l'irrationnel smea chez ses c'est
horrible c'est aberrant n'y a pas de
mots
toutes les formes de terrorisme je
condamne à mort moi je condamne à mort
je veux dire par là que c'est ccc
j'arrive pas à trouver mais mentalement
same same same as le déplacement on a je
te rassure mais
je crois que là on a décidé de d'akouda
l'exterminer tous les terroristes mais
c'est pas en exterminant les terroristes
qu'on va arrêter le terrorisme c'est
justement en exterminant les terroristes
pour fabriquer terrorisme voix sinon
l'algérie aurait plu déplu plus
d'incidents que belle lurette
non moi je moi j'ai pas la solution j'ai
pas la science infuse
simplement je crois que la solution est
politique qui voient la solution mais la
politique c'est quoi c'est sait comment
vivre ensemble qu'on va partager le pack
en partager l'eau arrêté d'humilier les
gens tu vois je
tout ce que je peux dire en tout cas
c'est que ça va être difficile d'être
arabe c'est en mettant ouais c'est tout
quand les gens dansent en palestine
après l'attentât qui a eu donc à new
york vous réagissez comme en jeu je suis
pas à la place de ces gens là je moi je
suis contre la mort je suis un citoyen
du monde
je trouve ça la mort c'est pourri de
mourir à moi je préfère à la place de
mourir d'aller aux bains douches et de
taper la deuxième à carreaux bleus
franchement non mais c'est vrai tu vois
je sais c'est vraiment c'est vous c'est
un vrai truc et que si ces mecs-là elles
sont confrontées à l'avoir matin midi et
soir je vous posais la question d'abord
vous posez la question parce que je suis
arabe musulman alors alors alors si si
si je n'ai pas la place de ces gens là
qui subissent quiconque une pression
incroyable qui crient tous les soirs en
rentrant chez eux après que leurs
cousins gain de mourir ou que leur frère
vient de mourir
il s'est donc ils sont là ils se
défendent à coups de cailloux ils se
prennent ils se font entre seront tués
tous les jours
il met ça sur le dos des états unis
d'israël israël et en étant très proche
des états unis ils font aussi eu aussi
des amalgames et c'est 100 fois plus
facile il faut savoir plus facile pour
eux de faire des amalgames que que pour
les autres je veux dire que ils sont
dans une situation tellement incroyable
les mecs que que je comprends pas du
tout mais je je je fais pas de mots moi
je sais pas penser que les américains
ont trompé d israël je pense rien du
tout pas l'enjeu jeu yaya il n'y a pas
de juste milieu
c'est dans la violence y a pas de juste
milieu il ya et je je pense que je pense
qu'ils que ce qui se passe en algérie ce
qui se passe en palestine ce qui se
passe au rwanda ce qui se passe ce qui
se passe ce qui se passe en irak avec
l'embargo
c'est pas normal c'est pas bien c'est
moi je suis dans une position super
confortable j'ai vendu 450 milles
cassette je je je je roule dans une
super belle voiture entièrement ma mère
allait la même souris avec les bras
grands ouverts
moi je fais toi je peux juste vous
trouvez ça horrible et puis et puis
prier pour que tout rentre dans l'ordre
maintenant maintenant je fais pas de
politique et puis j'ai jugé pas de
solution je ne connais pas les réponses
c'est horrible ce qui s'est passé est
d'accord on n'enlève en rien à ce qui
s'est passé horrible
là on en parle c'est à chaud j'aurais
aimé avoir cette discussion avec vous
dans six mois' j'aurais été beaucoup
plus objectif là là c'est horrible il ya
eu des morts il ya des iade il ya des
femmes qui faisaient le ménage dans la
twin towers des portoricains qu'avec eux
sont en embuscade rentrer chez elles car
elles quand elles ont rien à voir avec
tout ce qui se passe ni aux palestiniens
ni elles ont subi comme comme plein de
gens et le truc qui m'a quand même assez
frappé je dois l'avouer c'est que j'ai
vu l'information continue depuis que
c'est arrivé j'ai vu que ça sur toutes
les chaînes en permanence j'ai vu aucune
image depuis un an
deux des morts qu'a eue en irak parce
qu'il passe qui m'accueille d'afrique
n'a vu aucune image d d d d d
on a vu peu d'image du génocide au
rwanda on nous montre que ce qu'on a
envie de montrer ça c'est déplorable
c'est ce que je dis il ya des
informations qui roule ou mal an si on
décide de tout nous dire et à nous deux
protéines porter jugement là je pourrais
avoir un jugement lucide et
constructives mais là là je peux rien
vous dire que je vais vous dire ouais
c'est horrible
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dit maintenant ça va être dur de sortir
des blagues beau fils je sais je sais on
ne bouge pas pendant le jingle
[Applaudissements]
c'est qu'une seule envie quand on
demande à voir bouger c'est de bouger ma
fille d'habitude et beau jeu interview
croyance est ce que vous croyez que les
drogues douces conduisent forcément aux
drogues dures ou manteau rouge
[Applaudissements]
non pas du tout mais moi je ne sors
plein d'ennemis est ce que vous croyez
qu alain chabat peut sauver canal+ bien
évidemment sans problème à la super
alain chabat à la chaleur peut sauver
n'importe qui ouais ouais tu peux sauver
canal il peut sauver canal comme il peut
comme avec comme il peut trouver des
solutions
est ce que vous croyez au sexe sans
amour bien évidemment que non ça
n'existe pas à pas pour ma part si je
n'ai pas de sentiment je ne peux pas
produit fait donc vous croyez à l'amour
sans sexe jeu j'ai pas dit a fait ça
mais je pense qu'il faut qu'il peut y
avoir une forme d'amour qui n'est pas
palpable
concrètement n'a jamais pêché sans avoir
un petit sentiment moi jamais d'avis ce
serait se [ __ ] de la gueule de ma
partenaire et ça c'est pas possible il
faut qu'il y ait quand même un respect
mutuel respect passe par l'amour
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous croyez jamel debbouze ou
pouvoirs surnaturels
alors vous pouvez venir pendant mon
interview comme vous voulez voit pas
mais je crois qu'il a je crois qu'il ya
un petit sentiment pour toi mais oui
mais par contre sans sentiments je veux
bien même si tout est elle aussi en a
les autres est ce que vous croyez aux
pouvoirs surnaturels de goldorak
bien sûr tu es fou mais attends j'ai des
preuves un mandat je sais que doha qu'il
existait actarus avec de mon quartier
est vrai que chirac va être élu il ne
peut pas être est ce à cause des bruits
des odeurs
non je serai relou qu'il soit réélu jean
louis double foutent de la gueule d'un
autre président la république mois s'est
produit au connaît est ce que vous voyez
au père noël bien sûr
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est ce que vous croyez jamel debbouze à
l'effet des crèmes antirides
je ne prononcerai pas le sujet est trop
délicat
j'ai trop dédicace à mettre dans la
merde pas mal d'institutions d'accord
lui des tests cliniques prouvé dans les
laboratoires cocoa que les crèmes
antirides ça marche
excuse moi mais je connais des gens qui
depuis des années
mettre des crèmes anti rides et est ce
que vous croyez que patrick fiori peut à
nouveau rencontrer le grand amour après
sa séparation avec la raf additionne
demande comment il a fait pour le
rencontrer une première fois
[Applaudissements]
tout est possible après est ce que vous
croyez que l'homme a vraiment marché sur
la lune
donc c'était une manipulation des
studios d'hollywood séchait franchement
je me pose encore la question on en
parle souvent avec mes parents oui là
c'est vrai c'est bizarre quand tu
regardes bien moi j'ai pas moi ils sont
jamais retournés mais moi si cela était
une fois alors si bien dit mais bien sûr
on a été dit s'il te dis c'était
magnifique c'était un truc incroyable il
réalise y retourne pas donc un peu
peut-être c'était pas si incroyable que
c'est bidon et peut-être ils n'ont pas
été non est-ce que vous croyez en vous
bien sûr à mort s'il ya bien une
personne en qui je crois c'est web est
ce que vous croyez en moi et bottes de
plus en plus et figurez-vous au début
non au début je au début un peu après
non
après j'ai dit non il va droit au mur
geithner qui changera pas il pourra rien
faire et puis l'a fait petit à petit
figurez vous qu'un peu ça me fait
plaisir ça fait non mais c'est vrai en
plus je regarde chez l'une des rares
émissions que je regarde la télévision
moi je moi j'ai un hymne
[Musique]
c'est mon ami laurent et ligne de
laurent c'est ça
m
on est le tien vaut bien
[Musique]
moi depuis mardi dernier je ne crois
plus aux super héros ou et et bruce
willis mardi
djamel ses organes
plus en
mesdames messieurs acheter
ouais si jamel debbouze
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
j'arrête je comprend un petit peu ses
applaudissements et cet accueil par ce
que j'ai lu cette semaine dans le figaro
entreprises que vous étiez l'acteur le
mieux payé de france devant gérard
depardieu je les lui aussi j'étais très
déçu par ce qui a été
ce qui a été marqué parce que c'est
complètement faux j'ai touché le triple
ça va venir
que ce soit par les skis mal mais j'ai
le plus c'est la manière dont ça a été
présenté son journal de france 2 ce
qu'il disait à la grande surprise
générale bien sûr je voudrais peut que
les en deux parties non oui oui c'est un
fait
j'ai trouvé ça j'ai trouvé ça amusant ça
nous fait plus de deux millions d'euros
c'est beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
par jour tu avais combien de jours le
tournage en aime quand j'avais aucun
problème quand je touchais 3700 francs
contre emploi solidarité
j'ai aucun problème à toucher autant il
valait 1 autant d'argent aujourd'hui
comme assidus et remy l isf sans
problème je le répète que c'est bien
mais jamel en plus ça part vite l'argent
j'en ai plus j'en ai plus là parce que
mon frère mon mot à ma cousine
d'audincourt mon frère de taza et ma
voisine de discours de gérard philipe ya
plus personne tu te reste combien sur
les 2 millions la neige ne me restait
700 euros ça va vite en tout et pour
tout ça va vite et pour les impôts t'as
rien non non ça c'est pas toi je me suis
arrangée avec laurent moi je les perds
est sûre si cette pige dr djamel alors
vous venez de cannes là où vous êtes une
star absolue d'ailleurs j'ai vu dans
paris match que vous étiez avec les plus
grandes stars du festival qui apprécie
beaucoup votre le pas vrai j'étais avec
les amis de la weed
j'étais avec gt avec charles âgé tient
avec cai abdel kader aoun
j'étais avec qu'il y avait d'autres on
éjecté qu'indiquent des cailleras du 7 8
3 c'est le seul cela que je connais
[Applaudissements]
alors un parc anne vous passez beaucoup
de temps au maroc beaucoup de temps à
marrakech vous avez une maison jamel et
où vous avez monté des studios de cinéma
ouais ouais on les a pas encore ça fait
monter puisqu'on n'a pas encore on n'est
pas encore arrivé dans la phase où les
studios sont en construction mais on y
arrive on y arrive très vite et j'espère
une charlotte que dc dc prochain
festival du cinéma à marrakech
un opus posé la première pierre ah ouais
ouais j'ai été super surpris on tourne à
astérix de voir que j'avais je n'avais
pas d'à priori mais je ne m'attendais
pas à ce que les marocains connaissent
aussi bien le cinéma j'étais vraiment
surpris et de voir un premier assistant
parlait quatre langues différentes gérer
quatre mille personnes
je me suis dit mais j'ai rarement vu ça
mais qui parle français anglais arabe
dans la même phrase ça donne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais mais mais samassa massama je me
suis aperçu je le savais déjà mois mais
le maroc s'est pas car c'est pas qu'une
terre sera qu'un paysage c'est aussi des
gens genre tu vois ce que dirait qu'ils
connaissent bien leur caf donc ça me
paraissait évident et logique de montée
des sites des studios c'est une façon en
plus de faire du business et d'aider les
gens qui vivent là bas c'est vraiment
pas pour faire du business les studios
finalement ça rapporte pas tant d'argent
que ça ça en coupe d'abord beaucoup au
départ mais moi ma démarche première
c'est vraiment d'essayer d'amener de
faire en sorte que les gens de mon pays
puisse travailler dans les conditions
les mieux possible les plus normal
puisqu'on montrent d'abord avant de
monter des studios un centre national de
l'audiovisuel
ah ouais pour former les gens aux
premiers métiers du cinéma et la
démarche allait purement professionnel
d'abord avant d'être financière c'est
bien j'essaye germaine devons donc au
maroc à casablanca le vendredi 16 mai
cinq attentats suicide ont fait 48
victimes majorité de marocains plus
trois français deux espagnols un italien
pour en parler avec nous j'appelle
samira sitail
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
samira bonsoir donc vous êtes directrice
de l'information de la chaîne marocaine
2m
merci d'être avec nous djamel au maroc
j'imagine que c'est une star comme en
france qua non ah oui mais aussi connu
et même beaucoup plus connus je pense
aux inrocks ici puisque jamais elle
c'est la réussite
jamel c'est un symbole jamais elle s'est
pas uniquement la banlieue qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui il soit salué voir décrit
aussi par d'autres parce qu'ils touchent
le plus beau salaire de 3 ans ils vivent
jamais ce n'est pas social au maroc je
mêle s'est fait à la fois et c'est une
mégastar méga cela fait donc la gueule
maintenant j'ai amené mon avocat est
donc en plein milieu des festivités
organisées à l'occasion de la naissance
celui mais du premier fils de mohammed
vi le roi du maroc et deux jours après
l'aïd al mawlid la fête de la naissance
du prophète
cinq attentats à la bombe ou à la
voiture piégée visant essentiellement
des restaurants des hôtels fréquentés
par des étrangers ou lié à la communauté
juive ont eu lieu à casablanca
li membre des commandos kamikaze était
d'origine marocaine
il ferait partie d'un groupe islamiste
appelait le droit chemin
implanté dans la banlieue de casablanca
est rattachée plus ou moins à al qaïda
alors vous qui êtes directrice
d'information de l'important de chaînes
marocaines
que savez vous sur les coupables de
cette opération
ils sont tous marocains ce n'est pas
uniquement les huit en fait on a
identifié au jour d'aujourd'hui huit
cadavres sur les treize kamikazes qui se
sont donné la mort sur les différents
sites que vous avez décrit jeudi rossi
oui on a visé les symboles
on a visé des symboles qui font
qu'aujourd'hui le maroc est l'antithèse
la plus complète de ce que les radicaux
les intégristes défendent comme modèle
de société
nous leur faisons tous les jours la
démonstration de ce que le maroc peut
être un pays musulman profondément
attaché à ses racines profondément
musulman tout en étant un pays arabe
berbère
juif d'une certaine manière puisque
cette religion fait partie de l'histoire
du maroc
donc ces marocains qui sont touchés
lorsqu'on pose une bombe devant
l'alliance juive si les marocains qui
sont touchés c'est pas les juifs les
musulmans c'est d'abord cela est un juif
persécuté dans ce pays c'est quelque
chose de nouveau c'est quelque chose de
nouveau pour nous comme le sont ces
attentats imaginez qu'une ville paisible
se réveille un matin dans l'horreur la
plus absolue avec j'ai pas une ré cela
aux téléspectateurs mais c'est vraiment
le loreur et moi j'ai eu un fils mais
tout ça j'ai eu à voir tout cela mais
j'ai eu à faire des choix de ne pas
montrer le visage une tête un gamin qui
dort encore qui va s'éveiller avec les
images
peut-être de son père la tête coupée à
la une de notre journal j'ai refusé cela
j'ai voulu respecter cela et je crois
que tous les marocains quelque part sont
un peu comme moi aujourd'hui ils ont
cette attitude à la fois de surprise à
la fois brévol de colère et en même
temps et c'est ça peut-être si j'osais
dire à toute chose malheur est bon que
nous retiendrons de ce 16 mai qui était
le jour de mon anniversaire
nous retiendrons que nous sommes plus
forts et que notre modèle est le bon et
aussi que cette guerre antiterroriste
menée à l'échelle mondiale dans un
désordre absolu depuis 18 mois nous en
payons nous les marocains aujourd'hui
les pots cassés et que c'est un échec
absolu
mais
ce qui est important de dire c'est que
ça arrive au moment où le maroc
progresse vers une vraie démocratie où
l'on commença à s'inscrire vers le ce
qui m'a le plus étonné c'est que
vraiment c'est celle j'ai le sentiment
que mon pays mon pays a été touché au
coeur et et ans et en traître presque
parce que j'ai j'ai j'avais le sentiment
qu'on paye progressait axa axa que ça se
développait qu'on allait qu'on allait
qu'on allait vers une vraie ouverture
sais pas comment expliquer mes jeux gt
gt ou très bon pour moi pas parce que
j'ai jamais connu ça au maroc j'ai
jamais vu ma mère dans cet état là
jamais vu mon grand père ne s'était
jamais ma famille dans ces cas là et je
me suis aperçu que partout dans le monde
aujourd'hui on est on est on est plus à
l'abri nulle part il ya eu mille morts
sur les routes
il ya a été touché new york était de
champlain coeur paris pareil à vitrolles
ya catherine mégret
on est à l'abri nulle part donc
franchement aujourd'hui j'ai le
sentiment qu'il faut continuer à vivre
sa vie comme on l'entend et comme on dit
dans ma cité knicks à mr le maire
il faut quand même espérer que c'est pas
ces événements dramatiques ils vont
faire changer le maroc est bien au
contraire vous savez nous sommes à la
veille d'une très grosse manifestation
dans les rues de gaza
tout le monde descend demain tout le
maroc est dehors
demain je suive musulmans chrétiens
vivant dans ce pays puisque on en parle
et qu'il s'agit bien de cela nous
défendons cela c'est une partie de notre
identité nous combattrons l'intégrisme
et si nous n'étions pas conscient depuis
un an parce que c'est vrai on nous a dit
il ya des cellules dormantes
attention cependant quand on a parlé
samira quand on a parlé des cellules
dormantes
il ya beaucoup d'intellectuels et
certains journaux qu'on dit c'est une
manoeuvre du pouvoir en fait c'est
existe pas tout ça c'est pour aller vers
le tout sécuritaire et en fait c'était
vrai c'était vrai et depuis le 16 mai je
peux vous garantir que cette presse là
mais ces intellectuels là où ces gauchos
caviar qui hante la capitale économique
et rabat et qui ne finalement ne
connaissent pas très bien le maroc et
bien je peux vous dire qu'aujourd'hui
sont très mal à l'aise et qu'aujourd'hui
s'agit pour nous de protéger ce que nous
sommes c'est notre patrimoine c'est ce
que nous sommes et le marché le plus
important c'est pour le maroc c'est la
france 55 % du flux touristique au maroc
c'est le marché français et au contraire
et c'est ça qui est extraordinaire et
c'est pour ça que je suis heureuse
d'être là en france et sur ce plateau de
télévision
parce que les français ont dit non avec
les marocains ce terrorisme en dix ans
20 nous venons en aux réservations dans
les maintient le maroc le maroc c'est
aussi un peu chez nous voilà
[Applaudissements]
et vice versa on avait compris les
réactions mohamed 6 s'est rendu
évidemment sur les lieux du drame
alors moi métier c'est le commandeur des
croyants ça veut dire qu il est
commandeur de tous les croyants c'est à
dire les juifs les chrétiens et les
musulmans
les trois religions les trois religions
il est bien sûr musulman est la religion
majoritaire au maroc et l'islam mais il
est le protecteur comme le fut
d'ailleurs son grand-père et sa la
communauté juive séfarade le sait et
j'aurais pu moi même ils ont acclamé de
la côte est le gouvernement lui qui a
dit au roi mohamed 5 vous nous livrer
les juifs pour qu'ils puissent livrer
aux anneaux
il a dit je ne voulais livrerait pas
s'ils sont sous ma protection lorsque
d'espagne on les a chassés réprimer ils
sont venus au maroc ils vivent et je
répète je ne sais pas si je les exprime
bien ou si on m'abuse c'est bien
comprend entre le fait est que c'est ça
qu'on veut toucher et ce n'est pas
uniquement de le défendre nous du maroc
nous pays arabe musulman
revendiquant cette identité musulmane
pourtant nous projetons nous comme
n'importe quel citoyen de ce monde
aujourd'hui
alors moi médecis est en train de
démocratiser le maroc mais effectivement
plus de liberté c'est plus de liberté
pour les idées toutes les idées même les
idées islamistes c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui au maroc et des journaux
quand même très radicaux qui paraissent
aujourd'hui et depuis le 16 mai les
marocains je crois qu'ils se sont rendus
compte que c'était tous pareils que
c'est les moyens qui change
il ya ceux qui prônent la violence et
ceux qui prônent cette autre violence
encore plus terrible et meurtrière à la
une de leurs fourneaux pour les
marocains c'est tous pareils il faut les
combattre et nous les combattrons et ça
ne passera pas quelle était la réaction
du parti de la justice et du
développement qui est un parti
islamique qui est reconnue et qui
participent à la vie démocratique du
maroc
bien sûr qu'ils les ans témoin qui les
ont condamnés mais lorsque leurs
responsables elle a une de sept présents
vous parliez tout à l'heure
font l'apologie de ces groupuscules
radicaux qui aujourd'hui agissent sur le
terrain ils sont aussi responsables que
c'est treize kamikazes qui sont
marocains des jeunes qui se sont fait
encadrer et manipulés par des personnes
qui auraient pu être celle du pjd
mais le pjd a condamné les attentats et
pourquoi leur intervention n'a pas été
retransmise à la télévision marocaine
sur tvm je ne suis pas la tvm je suis
deuxième l'autre chaîne de télévision
mais le fait est que vous n'allez pas
dans un moment comme celui-ci où les
partis politiques progressistes de ce
pays et sont nombreux les rejettent leur
dise non faites votre manif tout seul on
la fera pas avec vous mais on fera la
mode de notre côté bon il est tout à
fait la réaction est tout à fait normal
et moi je le dis et je le revendique
je refuse comme ça a été le cas moi ça
tombe de responsables de la presse
française un moment donné qu'ils ont
décidé officieusement de banaliser leurs
discours leurs appels au meurtre
ce n'est pas cela la démocratie ce n'est
pas cela le maroc que moi je voudrais
que vous proposez finalement c'est qu'on
considère au maroc
le pjd comme en france le front national
est considéré c'est à dire qu'il n'est
pas admis en fait dans le jeu médiatique
votre comparaison est un peu caricatural
mais je vous dirais une chose elle me
convient tout à fait et je crois que si
vous me posiez la question de savoir
pourquoi tout d'un coup ils ont 38
députés au parlement je vous dirais
qu'on n'a pas vu venir la vague qui a
été celle de le pen
l'année dernière mais je passerai sur
les détails je dirais que la comparaison
n'est pas malvenu
john vous avez des copains qui sont
tentés par l'islamisme maroc ou en
france de la balle malheureusement
malheureusement dans le quartier souvent
les mêmes de mon quartier sont pas
respectés et un terroriste c'est quoi
enfin j'ai pas la définition mais je
pense que c'est d'abord à frustrer cela
convainc pas tout cas qu'on rejette
quelqu'un qu'on méprise et qu'est ce que
ça doit être profondément meurtrie je
crois pour pouvoir en arriver là et je
sais que certains mecs de mon quartier
non facilement se faire embrigader et se
retrouvant des histoires bizarres parce
qu'on n'est calcule pas mais si on les
écoute pas parce qu'on est on les
rejette en bloc et si j'ai réussi à m'en
sortir aujourd'hui sans prendre c'est
parce qu'on pense pas comme moi d'aller
on m'a dit tu es un mec bien continuer
le fons et et c'est devant ce discours
là que j'ai eu envie de faire mieux et
dans fear et de d'essayer de mieux que
je peux de décevoir personne
mais c'est sûr que que nous en tout cas
dans leurs bottes dans le banlieue comme
si comme je le répète souvent lyon on en
zone d'éducation prioritaire si on est
en zone d'urbanisation priorité ajouté
payeur et comment contourner canton
monde et converser en zone franche de la
fin les appels des zonards ce que je
veux dire c'est difficile et c'est sûr
que quand on trouve le réconfort dans
une mosquée enfin moi je ne comprends
pas mais je les jeunes explique en tout
cas cessé des mots c'est de voir un mec
qui dit tu es un mec bien continue lâche
pas pendant qu'elle domaine des tic dans
quel secteur d'activité dévolu ça fait
toujours plaisir
c'est vrai qu au maroc le succès des
islamistes radicaux c'est plus que leurs
prêches encore c'est la façon qu'ils ont
de s'occuper des gens ses accents soul
terrain ils ont des actions de
solidarité des actions caritatives
il ya que le pjd cas un vrai projet de
société on se demande si les autres
partis politiques qui sont en danger
démocratique au maroc ont des projets de
société aussi défini que pjd ça c'est
faux ces fautes chéri
ces fossés véhicule est effectivement un
syndrome de publications celles dont
vous parliez tout à l'heure il y en a
plusieurs y en a deux ou trois et c'est
aussi ce que les médias occidentaux
souhaitent retenir
vous le savez très bien on ne parle
jamais des trains qui arrivent à l'heure
on ne parle que de ceux qui sont en
retard c'est une très belle île à samira
lâche pas le morceau tout le tien le pjd
est un train qui malheureusement
arrivent en retard
bientôt on tente d'en juger elle
n'aurait la note juste juste à temps
ouais carrément sahel non attendez la
conac son nom
c'est par elle de parler d'histoire géo
localiser la laisser tranquille il faut
pas l'énerver
enfin ils n'ont pas de projet de société
ils n'ont pas de revendications ils
n'ont pas de message vous savez il joue
un peu sur cette fibre arabo-musulmane
attention et nous les arabes les
identités et ses joues sur cette fibre
mais en profite très franchement pour
mon pays c'est la première fois c'est
pour ça que j'étais choqué je vous ai
dit où le début d'émission que ça
m'avait c'est bon ça fait mal au coeur
de voir cet état là mais mais mais c'est
bien sûr que c'est grave mais encore une
fois plus personne n'est à l'abri donc
on en parle aujourd'hui moi vraiment sur
le coup j'étais très choquée et puis
finalement je me suis dit c'est la vie
je vais pas m'arrêter de vivre pour je
vais pas m'arrêter de continuer à aa les
noms n'est pas que cc c'est le début
pour moi presque
ouais je n'en ai pas qu'ici c'est pas de
la résistance c'est le début de l'ajout
et j'ai pas puis ça quand tu veux même
essaimé ces c'est le début si le début
parce que aujourd'hui je crois en mon
pays c'est un pays envoie quelqu'un qui
est plein de promesses
tu as déjà goûté un ratage et le mc faul
par exemple et comment ça déchire taj et
leur fou
oui ça a été mon premier voyage à
l'étranger et au maroc quand j'avais 16
ans alors franchement si vous priver de
tajines morte foule
puisse allah à cause de terroristes vous
êtes tous secousse marocain des couscous
tunisien alors là ya du poisson
personnes là mais tu vois juste n'avions
je voulais pour éviter de 2 s'est passé
il ya pas longtemps il faut ce terrible
en algérie et un tremblement de terre ça
fait 500 morts des milliers de blessés
on n'a pas de pot bordel de merde c'est
ça qui est en train de me dire on n'a
pas de pot et puis moi j'ai envie
d'adresser un message d'espoir à tous
ces algériens à tous ces marocains qui
souffrent plus et musulmans si l'on
regarde on est très regardée au maghreb
qui qui qui qui qui sont qui sont dans
le lot dans le noir il faut il ya truc
on se dit tous et cécile anne burlat tu
sais enfin à la fin de chaque phrase
abdullah tout va bien et j'ai envie de
leur dire du lien on est encore là où on
l'attend
il ne répond pas c'est pas possible
mais quand on termine en disant un mot
au sujet du roi du maroc qui regardent
souvent tout le monde en parle
est ce que est ce que vous pensez qu'il
va tenir bon face à face à ça il faut
juste peut-être dire que quand on dit
modery radical machin et cetera le roi
commandeur des croyants etc il n'est pas
le représentant d'un islam modéré
il est le représentant de l'islam coup
le ceux qui connaissent les livres qui
connaissent le courant et je vous invite
à le faire si vous ne connaissez pas ce
n'est pas cette haine qui se déversent
tous les jours en ce moment c'est cesser
de l'amour c'est de la tolérance et
beaucoup de vérités qu'on rende qu'on
donnerait les attentats bien sûr bien
sûr
alors lorsqu'on en brigade ces pauvres
dames un clan dit vas-y tu ira au
paradis
eh bien on leur ment on leur dit que
même la femme qui les attend et là ça
crève en même temps un vois moi
franchement je croyais vraiment
terroristes mais mais mais mais mais
mais les femmes c'est pas mal on a fait
quelques une mine
merci
à
exceptionnel
alors on va au maroc une femme peut être
directrice de l'information d'une chaîne
de télévision
ah ouais avec tout ce que ça implique au
maroc et c'est pas l'eau dans tu vois
c'est une meuf que j'adore ella ella
ella beaucoup de courage et beaucoup de
charisme
ouais ça me rase et une écoute j'te
kiffe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que je suis juste posé ferrat
dallas attendez je vais te présenter ça
va me rate vous présente jamel debbouze
ne présentait pas savoir quand je
connais tous vous aéroports tous les
reproches étaient tous vient pas
j'attends juste gérer à notre écoute
mais qu'est ce tu le fais là ouais comme
je sais que tu as beaucoup de boulot
aurais tu travaille comme un forcené
ouais j'ai préparé le but ce que j'ai lu
très intéressant long à lire prend son
temps oui à prendre son temps évidemment
c'est parce que je devrai comme j'ai pas
le temps moi c'est pour ça que je laisse
tirer lire il me raconta rien il regarde
tout le monde en parle pour savoir ce
qui attend les actes aux vins il est
très bien organisée en tout cas observé
que pour une radio londres j'ai kiffé
aussi je vous ai déjà dit et d'appel du
18 jours comme je suis né le 18 juin ça
me fait kiffer c'est parti à travers les
toiles en personne rien à dire j'ai eu
un cas qui enregistre au théâtre parce
que moi à moi je te décris les questions
pourquoi que tu perds ton temps tu m'as
fait des questions avant tout par un
avis de me poser des questions à la con
du style tromper csu c'est d'accord
pépère je me ménage fait comme si
j'étais pas au courant des questions
ouais bon pour rester cinq minutes avec
nous ben je vous remercie japon benjam
elle qu'est ce que vous faites là
n'entend jamais avant chanel
bon j'en ai dit ben tu respires jamais
ben jamais là oui je fais que c'était
bnl
ils sont en baisse attendent les
remettre dans l'ordre j'amène on n'y va
jamais bonsoir bonsoir thiery alors
jamel c'est vraiment un honneur un
immense privilège d'avoir l'honneur de
vous avoir ce soir parmi nous après ces
immenses triomphe que vous avez
accumulés ces quatre dernières années
vous êtes aujourd'hui l'un des acteurs
les plus doués de votre génération
djamel si ce n'est le plus doué qu'est
ce que ça vous fait aujourd'hui à moins
de 30 ans de vous retrouver au panthéon
des acteurs français
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais le panthéon c'est la fin mais on
lui
là encore 30 ans il a beaucoup de choses
à faire l'achat n'a alors jamais c'est
vraiment un honneur un immense privilège
d'avoir l'honneur de vous avoir ce soir
parmi nous après ces immenses triomphe
que vous avez accumulés ces quatre
dernières années vous êtes aujourd'hui
dans les acteurs les plus doués de votre
génération
si ce n'est le plus doué qu'est ce que
ça fait aujourd'hui de vous retrouver au
panthéon des acteurs français
je sais pas si on peut dire ça comme ça
ouais je sais pas si risqué panthéon des
triomphes tour eiffel gens rien à [ __ ]
c'est plus difficile c'est pas moi c'est
les jo c'est les autres qui vont au
moins une certaine navailles
extraordinaire moi je suivis plus tu
vois je suis pas trop grand je fais je
fais des choses naturellement pensé
c'est le style c'est le style c'est
clair pourtant djamel d'après le journal
de mickey vous êtes l'acteur préféré les
enfants je tiens à remercier les enfants
en particulier pour pour ça c'est vrai
et c'est s'est joué ça s'est joué à ça
entre mois plus tôt et c'est vrai
qu'entre un chien débile et un arabe
qu'à la classe et ont préféré le raid
comme elle jamel c'est quoi vos plus
grandes qualités à part bien sûr la
bogossité la générosité la même minute
et ça et iris est très difficile de
parler de soi
ouais j'ai envie de dire là la modestie
oui oui oui modestie c'est bien aussi si
ça fait 2-1 dans le genre modeste
extrait modèles ceux ci fit de vaud la
vedette alors est ce qu'il vend des
livres c'est incroyable ils vont vingt
mille livres par jour
c'est une énorme le en vente 500 milles
là c'est la première mort en tenant son
effigie et d'éviter comme des aéroports
de métro voici mois ci ses amis ses
savoir faire mais aussi en souriant a
égalé un record qui s'appelle le jamel
debbouze commenge chiffres t'imagines
finale j imagine si philippe de gaulle
premier du pognon sur charles de gaulle
roissy charles de gaulle étoile station
charles de gaulle est fou ils pourraient
s'acheter plein de cravate bordeaux
[Rires]
alors jamel en 2002 d'après le figaro
vous êtes devenu l'acteur français le
mieux payé
oui mais d'ailleurs ça va causer pas mal
de temps je dois oui parce que
maintenant gj je vois venir plein de
nouveaux cousins qui sont en galère
d'oseille qu'il débarque comme ça il ya
encore rien mais qui est venu me voir en
disant je suis le fils de ton père tu
dis donc ça voudrait dire qu'il serait
mon frère m'a dit ouais j'y suis et on
fera je t'aime mon fils veut rien dire
du tout passé à cause du figaro est en
pleine crise d'identité alors oui
effectivement
j'aimerais remercier le figaro pour cet
article de bâtards bons djamel alors
c'est votre grand retour sur scène en
décembre vous êtes venus ici pour en
parler merci pas du tout irish venu en
toute amitié
alors je suis pas venu faire de la promo
mobile c'est vrai que c'est mon grand
retour sur scène en même temps faut
forer un petit peu je joue au bataclan
inch'allah à partir du du 23 décembre
jusqu'au 11 janvier
c'est casino de paris 23 décembre
jusqu'au 11 janvier au casino de paris
après j'enchaîne avec le bataclan 10 13
au 18 janvier après c'est vrai que
l'olympia arrive le 20 janvier jusqu'à
ce que mort s'ensuive
c'est pas venu par en parler
véritablement de la question et si vous
voulez louer les places c'est à la fnac
ou virgin
le nouveau spectacle de jamel c'est quoi
le spectacle ça va s'appeler jamais elle
100% debbouze est pourquoi
jamel debbouze sinon je rappelais
différemment jamais vous pouvez le dire
en deux mots de quoi ça parle de moi à
de vous c'est pour ça que ça s'appelle
djamel 100% debbouze en fin de mois
c'est aussi mauvais qu'ils vous pouvez
me dire sans plusieurs mois j'aurais
fait j'aurais dit autre chose mais la
manne enfin voilà enfin venir voir le
spectacle pour savoir de quoi c'est pas
ça parle uniquement de loi
en quoi ça s'appelle l'accusé de cosse
et riz site est à son paroxysme de
question d'utiliser le temps cc c'est
son nom pendant mon premier spectacle je
racontais un petit peu j'étais très
surpris de faire ce métier avec tout ce
que ça implique et est maintenant de là
que je suis vraiment dedans c'est encore
plus étonnant c'est ce que je raconte ce
que je vais tâcher de raconter vous
croyez que ça va intéresser les gens
parce que tu crois que pour décor de
merde il intéresse les gens
bâtiment pour faire part de leurs te
voir avec l'émission et il me demande si
ça va intéresser les gens tu crois pas
de franchement sever et les pourris et
ces tags chez pas qui c'est ta
grand-mère café c'est assez rare ici
c'est la magie et d'adressé darty
musique les tags sorti les tortues
musique ont fait des tags est vrai qu'il
devait être sous jb c'est impossible je
vais te montrer ce que c'est que de tac
est exactement je vais faire venir des
aga mois augmente montrer ce que c'est
que détail quand tu t'inquiètes pas
encore encore une question que je bouge
maintenant que vous avez un succès
énorme que vous croulez sous les
sollicitations
vous pouvez nous dire est-ce que sucer
c'est tromper tu vois qu'il veut battre
en empêcher j'ai toujours qu'elle va
profondément un sadique
tu dois tu dois être honnête il doit
être fait huit ans a dit si tu essaies
tu t'es pas obligée composer avec eux
sur ce que cissé s'est rompu à toutes
les stars je ne peux pas te répondre à
cette question je préfère me taire la
mère regarde l'émission en paix c'est
ramadan
jamel est ce que tant qu'il est là c'est
assez incroyable de laval va revenir au
mois de février
philippe de gaulle mais est ce que tu es
ce que tu as une question à lui poser
philippe de gaulle
si vous êtes donc le fils forcément de
charles est ce que il aimer le rap est
ce qu'ils connaissaient tupac shakur
biggie smalls par exemple de son temps
comme ça et il lui arrivait de danse et
de partir en vrille ou par branches et
non mais regardez les jambes en feu
mais jamais jamais voulait prendre pris
en flag dans votre salon à craindre
la même jamais non jamais jamais jamais
été plus t il était très strict
carpostal non c'est pas ça mais comme ce
n'était pas dans son talent il préférait
regarder ceux dont le talent mais parce
qu'on voit les chefs d'état en peine de
mon point de vue en tout cas je suis pas
chef d'état de mon état je me dis que y
ils sont toujours obligés tout le temps
toute leur vie d'être sérieux oui semble
sérieux mais ça les empêche pas de
s'amuser parfois mais c'est un jeu sans
rire à tout moment quand même s'ils sont
pas un sourire et qu'on les voit pas
rire il ya des choses qui les amuse il
n'a jamais touché la résidence du frère
de temps il et il était plutôt gentil
plutôt été sage plutôt chef d'italie des
gentilles et et à jouer steve a ils
avaient affaire avec difficulté
forcément ils n'avaient pas que ça à
faire entrer par on l'avait fait venir
pour ça ouais non ça c'était un peu
aller le chercher si c'est allé le
chercher dans tout ça a fait comme on
dit chez moi
merci beaucoup merci filet de volley
ball mon père il est drôle entretien
avec michel tauriac
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
c
à chanter
vais revenir en février pour le deuxième
tome alors le spectacle donc c'est
d'abord au casino de paris c'est ça on
est au bataclan ensuite l'olympia c'est
ça charles à et c'est avec kader aoun
toujours tu l'écris avec kader et c'est
kader qui fait la mise en scène toujours
si l'on change pas une équipe qui gagne
on a fait ça sur le premier spectacle
c'est vrai que ça fonctionne et qu'on a
pris beaucoup de plaisir et je vois pas
pourquoi je changerai mon algérienne
pour rien au monde ne la lâchera je la
kiffe raider si tu m'écoutes change rien
kader si tu m'écoutes changerait de la
chance de travailler avec kader aoun
ces deux là sont ceux ci travaillent
d'ailleurs très content pour camer avant
toute chose c'est vrai que c'est un mec
parce que je sais que j'aime beaucoup
chez lui c'est que il vient du des mêmes
endroits que moi et vient de bobby et et
à la différence de moi il a fait
sciences po et c'est ce qui lui permet
d'avoir un certain recul sur bobigny et
je suis riche de son expérience à chaque
fois il fait profiter de tout ce qu'il
connaît et il a lu plein de bouquins que
j'ai pas eu forcément donc il fait la
syntaxe tout temps il a lu tous les
livres il a vu tous les films et toutes
les émissions
c'est bon c'est réglé chez comme j'ai
fait sciences po quelque part
salut ce que m'a offert hélène ségara
[Rires]
le problème c'est qu'on l'arrêté ap
voilà ça s'écrit c'est hélène ségara qui
tend à dire ça oui elle m'a offert aussi
des du foie gras mais le foie gras était
pas là devraient s'inspirer du rat
musqué ça lui ferait vendre plus de
disques ainsi on va en parler à orlando
[Musique]
gfr
jacques lamonde
[Musique]
oui là-bas au dehors
et maintenant le flash j'te là il faut
une petite frimousse et qui pour une
fois je n'aime que si michèle laroque
[Musique]
et voilà comment elle est belle c'est
vrai on peut pas dire le contraire en
charge et tous les deux vous avez des
supers dieu tout près à michel que tu
peux pas dire des trucs comme ça gratuit
ça a un impact sur notre président tu me
tues mais tu me dises à moi forcément
après je vais avoir envie qui se passe
quelque chose entre nous mais moi je
sais ça y est depuis longtemps cherché à
chaque fois qu'on se voit sur un plateau
de télé michèle laroque
on se dit qu'on va se revoir sans les
caméras après toi tu pars los angeles
moi je fais toutes mes émissions se voit
pas alors si on n'était pas la télé tu
me dirais tu joues tu me direz vous bon
ben je t'ai dit tu es ce que si on
n'était pas à la télé tu serais aussi
heureuse de voir que ce soir c'est déjà
arrivé
ouais ouais mais pas assez je trouve est
ce que tu te serais fait aussi belle sur
n'était pas la télé pour me voir mais
j'ai toujours vu moi aussi
resplendissante c'est le soleil
je n'étais pas là telle étude qui titre
ce serait laisser faire par exemple on
fait quoi si on était pas là des on
irait boire un verre on inverse tissu
que des planes endroit super voilà la
bouteille tfou toi tu crois que tu as dû
faire à l'envers avec connaît par coeur
ça fait 2 30 d'avancé ce métier là c'est
toujours moi michel g merdier sur scène
je vais prendre un chasseur s'est désolé
je voulais pas vers sa ville et
est ce que si on était paniqués les
michel tu me dirait vraiment ce que tu
penses de moi oui moi je connais un
thierry ardisson que j'adore parce qu'on
est double ouais et que et que et avec
beaucoup de sensibilité de gentillesse
et d'intelligence et je le pense et qui
a un autre série ardisson quand on
connaît pas que j'aie jamais rencontré
vraiment dont parfois on parle parfois
et j'espère que celui que je connais va
complètement tournage voilà y'a qu'un
thierry ardisson ce n'était pas la télé
je pourrais te je pourrais être dragués
tu es marié tu étais majesty sérieuse
alors cité par la télé on parlerait de
ton actu tu crois non on n'en parlerait
pas en fait on va en parler parce qu'on
est
mais non tout ce que tu t'intéresses à
tout ce que je fais tu me demanderez à
leur nom j'aimerais bien sûr en arrivant
je pense que je te demanderai de trois
questions
on m'a donné une compte pas d'accord et
je crois que ma lecture je crois que les
mecs ils ont décidé ouais j'avais dit
aux deux questions est-ce que ça va
intéresser le public mon spectacle
ouais tu vas voir qu'après cette
émission pour décor il va intéresser le
public
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jamel
chez toi non mais non nettoie fait comme
si de rien n'était vous continuez vos
émissions
[Musique]
allez-y allez-y voir on y va on a un
problème il n'a pas un caméra week à
tripoli je pense que ma veste et qu'il
n'a pas fait nous battons sourire en
bien il revient à tanit et l'oeil de
triche tag c'est le mec de blanc dit tu
sais moi je suis désolé s'est quittés
potes qui sont avec toi là ddd des
repris de justice
[Applaudissements]
alors michel cymes à michel qui va
tourner dans [ __ ] dure donc avec
d'armand dutronc dany boon a exactement
mais je crois qu'on va beaucoup s'amuser
et dany boon tu l'as tu l'as vu ces
temps-ci non la dernière fois que je les
ai vus j'ai pas vu sa pièce mais je vais
y aller mais à la fois c'était il était
en vacances à megève il a aidé voilà il
avait l'air en forme et j'ai remis de sa
séparation d'avec judith parce qu'elle
était la semaine dernière bell a l'air
de s'être bien remise de sa séparation
le souci je crois non non non
catherine humaine terry as majeure du
navigateur il me demande si on peut
aller chercher une baisse de secours
chez moi catherine mais si je donne le
code comme je fais une autre émission
chez moi me donne le code catherine
c'est mort c'est dommage que philippe de
gaulle soit parti le nahd a honoré qui
fait faire philippe de gaulle nous sort
la tête des valeurs de gauche c'est sûr
donc judith godrèche était là la semaine
la semaine dernière elle avait l'air
d'avoir assez bien appris sa séparation
d'avec dany boon sa allen en étant mieux
oui dany ça va aussi
j'ai l'impression que ça ne les rend pas
s'en faire pour un nombre
alors il ya aussi un coffret qui va
sortir avec ils s'aiment et 56 minutes
voilà avec pierre pas il se fait
engueuler non non ça va les caméras
oui un coffret qui sort avec kit somme
ils se sentent eux mais voilà c'est ça
la saga complète tu penses tu fais quoi
michel quand tu pars tout le temps à los
angeles comme ça alors moi je prépare un
film j'ai acheté les droits d'un livre
qui s'appelle pitch de caroline bon
groupe je le connais voilà bien sûr et
on voudrait faire un film inspiré de ce
livre attias faire un film savez le
pitch peut-être alors tu vas venir le
pitch est ici un max obligatoire est
alors je n'étais pas la télé ce que je
pourrais couper les moments où j'ai
l'air con quand je te regarde jamais
l'air con c'est vrai oui c'est une idée
que tu te fais tu m'impressionnes
souhaitait pas la télé tu dirais quoi du
décor de cette émission
franchement il ya un truc que j'aime
beaucoup c'est la veste mais vraiment
pas je suis ça sert je trouve que c'est
un petit suspens car tout petit truc je
vais la signer way up
ouais
ces bons d'achat
est ce que va devenir la valérie sa part
comment sur la porte
axa pas réellement ouais tu crois que là
je suis comme ça pour un long moment on
peut faire mal et riz un des lingettes
les logettes la revient avec des
lingettes valérie je continue interview
de madame laroque
je termine du coup ci alors ce n'était
pas la télé tu aurais quoi comme
problème à me raconter je sais pas ce
qu'il ya eu dans le ciel les armes et
caetera que les gens qui étaient un peu
fragiles sont allées très très très mal
ouais j'avais plein de coups de fil de
gens qui allaient mal et ça m'a vraiment
inquiété voilà c'est ça les problèmes en
fait non d'essayer de jean phlippe un
peu lancement lâchement c'est la période
de l'année sinon messi n'est pas comme
si peu si je sais que ça ouais ouais
et puis comme je suis maintenant entre
les deux c'est quand je reviens je ne
sent plus ses chances parce que j'ai pas
subis tu vois toutes les pressions ici
et je trouve que parfois c'est très
lourd
il se trouve que les gens sont plus
flipper enfin aux états unis en france
c'est différent ils sont très forts avec
vous je chante mais la cause de bouche
mais disent non mais sa légende en plus
le moral
il ya eu quelque chose on est de 12
ouais je trouve un truc est absent les
gens ont pu la pêche non qu'est ce qui
se passe là bas ils retirent pas
catherine dîner dans la loge vip
d'accord ok je viens d'assister une
chose extraordinaire ici j'espère que
t'as pas mis un costume neuf non c'est
oui mais je n'écoute pas n ont pas amour
est un jouet thierry thierry toutain
chic type pensait pas voir ça
sérieux
[Applaudissements]
il s'est enfui il s'est enfui à le janet
dia si quelqu'un pouvait maîtriser jamel
debbouze personnage il question à poser
à thierry thierry tu m'entends je tente
en jammer comment tu peux mettre des
photos pareil sérieux quoi qui axe mais
david mali della quoi rien mauvaise mise
sur cette photo mais c'est le style de
la photo djamel troll
olala ça t'apprendra à dire que mon
spectacle n'est pas intéressant bouffon
alors même si l'on n'était pas la
télévision même je ne sais pas la
télévision
est ce que tu me parlerait quand même de
gerpinnes teurs ouais ouais c'est bien à
temps qu'est-ce qui se passe non non non
non non sérieusement écoute moi on va
lui ont valu amène weiskopf d'entre
elles laissent pas faire l'acteur qui
fait catherine on est avec toi
attends attends le prix internet deux
minutes comme toi dans ton new york mais
que je te parle public atteint ce avec
des filles jeunes balade je compte mes
filles je te parle
1 1 c'est j'arrête je te papa c'est
sévère
bien et ben voilà dans catherine barma
catherine barma elle aussi patent jamel
debbouze wallard lalala lalala
non
je trouvais pas de bouquet vous ce n'est
qu'un homme ça nous ferait peut-être
plaisir c'est le seul truc que j'ai
réussi à table et n'a pas trouvé plus
grands noms mais bien à la hauteur du
talent de maria pacôme suis désolé non
mais je vais la garder une veste peinte
par jamel debbouze up allait se classe
elle l'a une veste peint par jamel
debbouze qui savait tu devais être
ridicule à l'antenne je sais pas lequel
les questions sont atteints ce qu'elle
en pense on en dit on ne dira toujours
sont les étudierai ça c'est bien voilà
la télévision
[Applaudissements]
les ailes à ce que je propose c'est
pendant cette petite pause on écoute
l'île de michèle laroque choisi
spécialement pour elle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'émission
j
j'ai ça aussi ça c'est bon ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça
façon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mouallem
[Applaudissements]
et
ça aussi
et voilà je savais toi tu le sais mais
maria vous savez que jamel remonte sur
scène et la salle c'est un événement
quoi je vous ai toujours l'événement
effectivement quand est-ce que tu
remontes alors du 13e descendre au 18
décembre au casino de paris
ensuite je sonne du vin enfin j'ai pas
l'exacte et date exacte mais c'est
casino de paris bataclan olympia et vous
êtes les bienvenus mais parce que j'ai
raté la première fois que je sois là
jamais le 100% debbouze donc je voulais
profiter de cette émission pour pau pour
pour faire une petite annonce
mais lille peut venir de seconde ah oui
alors c'est ses mails ils t'appellent
méline fait longtemps que c'est comme ça
et v sicilienne son vrai nom c'est
mélina made in may line à l'origine
c'est une basket que j'ai signé moi-même
l'asse écrit jamel debbouze
ouais avec marc et en arabe ici espoir
et etc c'est parce qu'il a dessinée oui
s'il basket conques est destiné les
bénéfices de cette basket sont destinés
à aider les enfants des rues au maroc
par le biais de l'association l'heure
joyeuse et plus en vendre plus on en
vendra puis on aidera des gosses qui
sont défavorisés pas seulement au maroc
mais mais un peu partout dans le monde
et je voulais faire un peu la publicité
de cette basket bon bien sûr elle
s'appelle jamel debbouze elle est
extraordinaire est allé comment elle
déchire sa mère cette paire de pompes
c'est exactement la même là whaou
[Applaudissements]
m
je veux juste profiter de cette émission
pour dire qu'elle est en vente bientôt
je vous en supplie acheter là
[Musique]
m
à demain
un châtelain
[Musique]
oui la raho des eaux
jamel debbouze je vais crémazie d'y
aller parce que j'ai des courses à faire
ouais c'est que c'est vraiment dans ce
sens elle ramadan faut que j'aille
acheter de la rivale l'aise la bia du
meurtre l'autre et si j'ai pas mal dans
les magasins vont bientôt être fermée
vas-y c'est quand tu veux je j'ai adoré
cette émission peut [ __ ] le bordel
comme ça c'est toujours un plaisir et
plus le bordel mieux je me bats toi
ouais bien tu avec le move est là ou
quoi chez qu'à beauvais en creux zhu
spectacle chants rêver up direct pour
vous pour rejoindre la petite troupe
ça s'est passé comment extraordinaire
les gens debout tous mus mme jetté de
l'argent quand on vient nous voir
non extraordinaire âge et je kiffe
vraiment riche je me promène les gens
sont contents je suis ravi bien c'est un
spectacle quand même beaucoup plus
politique donc que le premier non il ya
plus de fonds gd plus c'est vrai les
gens ils ont il s'aperçoit tout
doucement que j'ai une conscience
politique
j'ai une conscience politique des plus
beaux jours de ma naissance je suis
engagée depuis 1875 et jusqu'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui à des choses tellement
tellement visible tellement flagrant de
ne pas faire qu'on va pas faire
autrement que d'en parler de les
dénoncer et moi mon stade je ne fait
qu'en parler sur scène quoi ça reste
encore un petit engagement ouais mais
c'est drôle en même temps c'est pas une
dénonciation agressive
non je sais rien faire d'autre 3g c'est
la seule manière de m'exprimer 18 juin
c'est bien comme elle à peine dix jours
de l'appel du général
c'est fou - ah tiens on a une question
de philippe de gaulle tient à ce que
serge est ce qu'on peut envoyer parce
que c'est que c'est ton pote comme la
dernière fois bien sûr figé et tu sais
ce qui m'a dit j'ai redire des films et
géré déjeuner avec lui il me dit qu'elle
est vrai que j'ai la casse est quand
même qu est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui m'a dit
'je ahmed en arabe or moi je suis bien
pour lui qu'il ait pas digne quand même
donc j'ai dit d'abord on va faire
traduire qu'est ce que vous lui donnez
là qu'est ce que j'avais dit après un
truc très sympa un père c'est très sympa
mais là il va te parler parce qu il
ils pouvaient pas t'attendre avec
plaisir serge magnéto si j'ai une
question à lui poser
on regarde ce qu'ont les diffusera tout
à l'heure non parce que il a tout le
succès que son talent mérite et c'est
très bien ainsi car c'est un homme
d'esprit je me suis aperçu qu'il avait
beaucoup d'esprit ça lui fera plaisir
ah oui par exemple quand il m'a dit à
moi je débarque à roissy charles de
gaulle qu'est ce que vous devez toucher
comme droits d'auteur c'est une
miraculée bellevue cette émission voilà
et tes potes avec la famille de gaulle
moi je l'écris fin je les connais par
coeur je les ai tous leurs trucs je vais
partout ils font j'ai été ajoutés sur
les ronds-points g/t au sur 1 à
l'aéroport je connais tous vos sites
mais de gaulle lâchez rien continuer
ouais pratiquement moi j g j'aime bien
le papa aussi
enfin j'ai pas tout aimé chinois comme m
il a fait des trous balourds faut pas
oublier l'un des records il a quand même
mis aux galères bon nombre de
tirailleurs marocains c'est les gaziers
quesnoy et il a quand même inventé le
deuxième bureau il a quand même interdit
ces gens de défiler le jour de la
victoire sur les champs-elysées hélas
quand même frustré bon nombre de
d'immigrés que tu es venu pour aider la
mère patrie
donc la famille de gaulle je viens bien
mais pour prendre l'avion
[Rires]
ça va pas trop chaud va bien
tu vois tes traits chez moi j'ai moi
j'imagine une doudoune chez vous ça va
du tablier comme sega va se marier c'est
pour ça qu'ils chanteront une
catastrophe c'est vrai mass marines 3
avec kylie à david david je voulais
c'est pas vrai donc c'est fini avec
galles c'est fini reygades galgala jeu
n'a pas gad ce que je vais t'aider sinon
la tournée
non parce qu'on se connaît bien avec
d'asus ça n'a rien à voir
alors quand ça parce que en tournée par
exemple le toit je regardais un
documentaire steinfeld qui était en
tournée aux états unis
le mec il est une mercedes et lui il
conduit sa mercedes ou 50 est en tournée
taqwa 50 personnes avec toi on est 30
ouais mais je conçois pas la tourner
différemment j'ai toujours tout seul
dans sa chambre d'hôtel et une
soldatesque dans sa petite voiture aussi
mercedes qu'elle soit c'est pas
intéressant pour y aller en bus à 30
un peu à la moitié que c'est un peu le
rolling stones au concert nous non mais
où le sol est pas ce que tu veux si tu
m'aimes j'ai fait des tournées c'est
génial c'est les meilleurs moments de la
vie c'est alors et vous auprès des
ballets même date
ce serait ridicule mais c'est un monde à
l'envers à contre-pied algérien moi je
suis aux mines moitié algérien moitié
marocain moitié français moitié cela
vous moitié plein trip du sang froid
aussi
n'empêche je suis je suis ouais j'suis
d'arabie c'est un enfant du soleil c'est
tout ils ont fait un truc sur le départ
des giants 62 kg s'est alors vu pareille
pourtant l'offre c'est bourré de jean le
loeuff que tu as acheté à saint germain
rue du four la fille j'ai pas acheté un
jeu lui loue mais c'est vrai qu'il est
plaint tout le temps il ya beaucoup de
mètres carrés donc j'ai encore une fois
saint-germain-des-prés ça vaut la peine
d'être vécue si ces vécus et qu'elle
fait tout
d'ailleurs c'est vrai bien ses potes qui
débarque guy béart juliette gréco c'est
plutôt cela mais mais sinon sinon les
savants on dirait la mjc de nanterre mon
appartement j'en suis très heureux ce
jury des mails des fois je retrouve dans
le frigo une fois 0 des deux minutes que
je vois
c'est passé c'est la maison tout le
monde désolé j'ai pas la cendre et qui
t'a pas temps d'en profiter sur la route
là c'est jusqu'à j'ai regardé était sur
la route jusqu'à la mi décembre
ouais mais c'est un vrai qui je toujours
c'est ce que je préfère faire
j'ai agi en rapport avec le public en
plus aisés les gens sont contents
d'accueillir je prends un malin plaisir
à y aller je kiffe
d'ailleurs je veux remercier tous les
gens qui sont dépassés ce sera coupée au
montage qui était venu à petit devenu un
vrai sex symbol nom depuis que tu as du
succès non non on attend il pas il
paraît que quand tu rends dans ta
chambre du foyer des filles qui
t'attendent moi ça m'est arrivé une ou
deux fois mais si tu sais ce que c'est
quoi ces sapins la routine c'est non non
non non mais c'est vrai que que depuis
que je touche l'usf c'est plus facile
hein
ouais ouais ouais mais j'ai aucun
problème j'assume pleinement hochtief
c'est extraordinaire
[Applaudissements]
des parents cela ils vont très bientôt
un nouveau jour d'ailleurs savez que
vous les doigts
ouais méditer dira bonjour à terrena
redescendre ils sont hors des zones hors
des zones s'est séparé c'est à dire un
truc génial tu as dit chez moi l'homme
que je respecte le plus c'est ma mère et
tu as dit elle avait cette gosse et la
réussit à nous faire croire qu'on
n'était pas pauvre sur sa géniale
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est vrai je m'habille une enfance est
super heureuse la mère a toujours fait
en sorte qu'on ait besoin de rien et est
et quand des fois n'y avait pas grand
chose à manger ends et du pain et du thé
vous nous expliquer qu'elle avait pas
tant de faire à manger donc le pari le
tc ce qu'on sait ce qu'on préférait drop
de la gagne on dit chez nous et j'aurais
pu passer
c'est vrai qu'à faire le conseil s'en
faire causette mois ma mère m'a laissé
un être incroyable à elle été fois mais
chez bouygues on faisait le ménage elle
était heureuse comme tout elle courber
l'échiné était d'accord avec tout
bascule la mer comme comme beaucoup de
mal à travailler dur pour être pauvre
chaleur doc dont il savait négligeable
moi je les gelées vue je l' ai vécu et
je peux pas l'oublier ya plein de mamans
qui sont dans les mêmes conditions
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui manière là la
chance de plus travaillé et et attaque
le piston que toi qui peux pas y trouver
des ménages à faire tomber mais non
c'est bon alors être étaient fous toi
maintenant un an et aux bahamas en train
de bronzer dans cette scène tupac shakur
comme ça ton père bon mon père il est un
peu plus peu plus comment dirais je vais
silk way we were il es t il et il était
forcément beaucoup plus dur mais c'est
normal sont habitées dans un quartier
dur mon père mon père il était dur mais
était d'une générosité incroyable je te
jure je me souviens d'un jour regarder
une publicité à la télévision qui disait
qu'avec différents pouvaient nourrir
toute une famille au rwanda plus à la
toucher il a essayé d'envoyer toute ma
famille au rwanda
salut c'est moi je l'équipe long terme
at il dit par exemple que il voulait
jamais voulait pas que je sois comédien
et moi aujourd'hui comme et de gueule
c'est pour les [ __ ] et les immo
sexuelle ligue du diamant du cg au maroc
il ya un lien le ccp qui s'affiche en
bas de l'écran pour envoyer du pognon
j'allais venir
moi j'ai toujours cette association qui
s'appelle leur joyeuse 1e charih si tu
pouvais laisser l'adresse bien
évidemment heureux sur l'écran elle
défile regarder remercie donc leur
joyeuse qui bien évidemment être ces
sinistrés au maroc à lima
nous on a envie de monter une opération
avec zinedine zidane comme parages les
solitaires sollicité la semaine dernière
il était était super partant on va
essayer de monter une opération pour
aider les sinistrés marocains et
algériens des derniers séismes via un
concert où j'aimerais en parler chez toi
volontiers voilà donc si vous avez des
couvertures des cuillères des petits
suisses envoyés au maroc n'hésitez pas
on est preneur via leur joyeuse
[Musique]
dommage ils venus de la base et toi tu y
vas fin d'accord d'accord ce qui est
bien chez ben laden ce qui nous a fait
préférer le train
bien sûr avec ben laden si possible si
jamais ça s'arrête demain ça sera cause
de toi
le jour le plus heureux de ma vie
ça fait dix ans qu'ils durent le vrai
problème du foulard à l'école c'est
surtout pour la piscine sinon c'est bien
[Applaudissements]
depuis que je suis connue c'est plus
facile pour les autographes les gens
aimant demande avant il en avait rien à
[ __ ] je rêve où les distribuer dans la
rue kruyt star flyer pour le soir et
rails
c'est cool il ne faut pas vendre la peau
de l'ours
surtout si l'on sait des dents encore le
bureau lyonnais vie sociale pacino qui
me la piquer dans scarface un nom sera
s'était taillé sur mesure pour moi non
et finalement nous dans la vie ce que je
sais faire le mieux c'est c'est pas moi
qu'il faut demander ça mon ex
ça va je peux me la raconter de temps en
temps qu'est-ce qui a pu jamais lequel
je me la raconter je me racontes là
parce que je préfère chez charles de
gaulle c'est son aéroport c'est sûr
quand je regarde la télé quand je
regarde la télé moi aussi maintenant
j'ai peur des arabes à l'âge que je peux
dire est ce que je préfère chez
dieudonné
ce que je préfère chez dieudonné
sa rapidité d'esprit non mais c'est vrai
parce que là c'est tellement c'est tu
flippes maintenant tu parles est devenu
c'est extraordinaire alors que c'est
disproportionné ce qui lui arrive je
trouve vraiment même s'il n'était pas
très drôle le jour de france 2 chez
marc-olivier fogiel de rendez hommage
ouais il me rendait hommage donc j'ai
dans une situation délicate mais c'est
vrai que j'ai été jouée à liège la ya
pas très longtemps et là bas aussi il a
été interdit donc je trouve vraiment que
ça prend des proportions incroyables je
peux vous le dire et je le signe du
délai n'est pas antisémite
il faut keraval et qui s'excuse dans ce
cas-là falloir lui demander à lui
directement parce que moi j'ai s'excuser
et on leur pardonnera s'il s'excuse
franchement il faut il faut s'excuser
serravalle ce qu'ont à dire les anges et
dj s'excuse je voudrais dire qu'il est
il qu'il ait empêché mi temps dans tout
ça veut dire que malheureusement
peut-être que il a fait une gaffe wa lâ
ilâha lycée mais c'est parce qu'il sait
pas ce que c'est parce qu'il dit là il
est nommé le dis parce que je lui au
téléphone il m'a dit j'ai été maladroit
ce n'est pas craindre de combattre
oui alors moi c'est oui alors dans ce
cas là vous êtes aurait dû être le
moment il m'appelait
maintenant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voici jamel debbouze
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jamel
je vous demande de vous arrêter
et ces substances est jamais qu est ce
qui vous en payez ou quoi alors ça va
super bien d'accord at il enchaîné
j'ai lu dans vsd tu vas me dire c'est la
soirée vsd mais j'ai lu dans vsd que la
dernière fois vous êtes allés aux
enfants de la télé arthur vous a pas
trouvé assez drôle vous a reproché de ne
pas assez faire le show d'avoir nique et
son émission et vous avez dit j'ai envie
de lui dire casse toi re tueur alors je
vous dire ici vous êtes en famille si
vous voulez pas être drôle c'est pas
grave
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors c'est difficile pour jamel
debbouze de pannes drôle parce qu'il a
été récemment sacrée artiste le plus
drôle du monde sur m6 voilà merci
il ya un sondage via un sondage énergie
ou jamel a été élu deuxième artiste
préféré des auditeurs derrière madonna
ça va derrière madonna
[Applaudissements]
homme comme l'année d'avant
comme l'élément il était l'artiste le
mieux payé de france c'est un livre des
records à lui tous à jamel debbouze
[Applaudissements]
merci alors c'est toujours un vrai
plaisir de venir chez toi tu sais on est
en retard
merci je suis je suis content alors
record également dans le nombre de dvd
de 100% debbouze mis en vente cinq cent
mille exemplaires mis en vente c'est la
plus grosse mise en route encore c'est
la plus grosse mise en vente pour un
humoriste au one man show 500000
exemplaires alors djamel sérieux c'est
bon je te barrer
rien à rajouter c'était super gars est
un vilan on est à 25 cents mille la
promo seydoux est d'enfer souhaite une
tuerie dont tu vas faire que des télés
que des radios toute la journée ou quad
à la c'est vrai quoi voilà est là là là
là je dois avouer que ça apple marathon
mais c'est un vrai qu'ils font pas se
voir je passe voir tes est nommé mon ami
arthur j'ai plein de gens à voir comme
ça elle a remarqué il ya deux dvd il ya
un premier dvd avec le spectacle que
vous avez co écrit avec kader aoun
moi non plus je connais pas non plus que
kader aoun qui est également responsable
la mise en scène
et puis il ya un bonus sur le deuxième
dvd alors il ya le making-of alors on
voit comment vous comment vous approchez
vos spectacles vos doutes vos angoisses
c'est pas c'est un travail de longueur
et c'est ça ouais
le résultat est marrant mais ce qui se
passe avant il ya des jours c mais c'est
comme toi tu t'es pas obligé de te lever
le matin de préparer des interviews sur
youtube je passe pour un con ben voila
sinon c'est quoi qui est obligé de faire
le show c'est comme tout c'est une
question de travail d'abord il faut il
faut bosser pour pouvoir être à l'aise
alors survenues cias a donc les
interrogations de djamel sur son métier
sur le spectacle il ya des rencontres
avec un certain nombre de personnalités
et puis le petit pont avec zidane 1 sur
la pelouse du stade de france j'ai envie
de chialer
non mais vous rigolez pas là c'est
vraiment ça c'est un tête à tête avec m
[Applaudissements]
dans le vent
dans la vie
là là il ya un tête à tête avec gym dix
musées dame au stade de france
et c'est pas lui qui a gagné voilà c'est
tout malade alors il ya bientôt mère 6
mai qui fait la première partie de votre
tournée et puis le spectacle après le
spectacle enfin bon voilà quoi
on s'est pas foutu de la gueule du monde
en récession non c'est sûr mais mais
mais mais vraiment pour parler un peu
plus sérieusement moi je suis très fier
de ce spectacle pour plein de raisons
parce que parce que effectivement ça
s'appelle pas 100% debbouze pour rien
avec kader on sait on s'est vraiment
approché le maximum de de la forme de
spectacles qui m'intéressait le plus à
savoir le stand up c'est un peu à la
manière d'aider des anglo saxons richard
pryor eddie murphy tous apprécié des
meilleurs mais bruce wayne lenny bruce
et et et j'adore j'adore cette forme de
spectacle parce que c'est ça reste une
conversation et à l'impression d'être un
cousin voisin oncle qui était qu arrive
sur scène comme comme dans son salon et
qui te raconte ce qui lui est arrivé la
veille c'est c'est un vrai qui fait
parce que c'est jamais la même chose et
c'est super marrant si ce qui est plus
dur quand même arriver tout seul sans
avoir des sketches que les gens
connaissent juste en parlant comme ça
devant une salle et avoir le contact les
faire marrer moi j'ai vu le spectacle
deux fois à chaque fois les gens étaient
pliés de rire
j'adore ça a vraiment bossé sur notre
activité un terme inventé un sociaux de
ma part j'avais dire c'est sincèrement
c'est bizarre de dire ça mais c'est vrai
que c'est il ya un truc qui passe entre
le public avec le public à ce moment là
elle est avec les sketches si je pouvais
pas croire tenir ça parce que ce qui est
enfermée dans un personnage dans une
situation ok une chute gens alors que là
c'est la joie alors dans le bonus on
vous voit chercher des vannes avec kader
aoun et moi je vous ai vu à l'époque je
me souviens de votre flip avant là avant
la tournée parce que c'était le deuxième
spectacle c'est pas évident le premier
avait été un énorme succès et il fallait
transformer l'essai c'était pas gagné
d'avancé
non mais d'ailleurs si jamais gagné
d'avancé mais ça c'est vrai que le
deuxième c'est toujours plus difficile à
aborder que le premier le premier on y
va avec une certaine fébrilité
et puis le deuxième c'est là où il faut
plus ou moins confirmée même si c'est
pas la pression du public qui comptait
pour moi à ce moment là c'était vraiment
la prime à la moye pour moi un jeu
choisi choisissent les les les mots et
que je me trompe pas sur ce que j'avais
envie de raconter j'avais envie de
raconter tellement de choses que ça
allait dans tous les sens et kader m'a
beaucoup aidé pour ça d'ailleurs si tu
m'écoutes l'algérienne je te kiffe ce
qui est bien avec vous c'est que votre
énorme succès ne vous est pas monté à la
tête va pas péter les plombs ça c'est
faux ah non pas du tout non si j'ai la
grosse tête mais ça c'est ça se voit pas
l'image n'est pas du tout et puis en
plus malgré le succès vous avez pas
fermer votre gueule
vous n'êtes pas devenu trop
politiquement correct il ya une phrase
comme ça vient de spectacles en 10
lancers l'ascenseur social il est bloqué
au sous sol
il sent la pisse non mais mais mais mais
bizarrement ça c'est même ça s'est même
renforcé ma conscience politique
cc c'est même plus plus plus ma plume
avis s'adoucit je dirais même plus je
suis détendu et plus je me rends compte
qu effectivement quand je vivais à
trappes
j'ai accepté des choses que j'ai
j'accepterai plus jamais aujourd'hui et
le fait d'arrêter habite aujourd'hui à
saint germain des primes après il m'a
fait prendre conscience de beaucoup de
choses c'est sûrement des prêts c'est
mieux ça sent bon pas aux gens qui
aiment le silence qui est épouvantable
et nuit un méchant possible impossible à
dormir le soir obligé d'aller voir le
voisin pour leur dire c'est pas bien te
fait du silence
mais de nous mais elle pas pris la
grosse tête vous n'avez pas renier vos
origines mais vous n'êtes pas vendu non
plus parce que vous avez refusé par
exemple de faire le prochain film de
francis veber gramat des plus grands
réalisateurs français parce que voilà
c'était pas votre cas vous avez pas
envie de le faire moi j'adore francis
hébert j'adorerais mais beaucoup de ses
films l'emmerdeur la chèvre les compères
j'en passe et des meilleurs mais mais
c'est vrai que là je m'attendais pas à
mieux mais mais mais mais à différents
c'est sûr que c'est sûr que camper le
personnage de françois pignon ça
implique enfin je veux dire par là que
je je je m'attendais à autre chose
en fait mais mais j'aspire à travailler
avec lui en s'éclatant c'est pas c'est
pas perdu mais mais sur ce coup là non
on a dit que le film s'est pas fait
parce que vous demandiez 3 millions 1,5
euro 4,4 millions vers 9 g/t
je lisais le scénario on avait on n'a
rien négocié du tout on a vingt jours
rien négocier aujourd'hui c'est d'abord
artistiquement que ça se passe si si si
si le personnage le scénario ne nous
convient pas il hors de question de
négocier quoi que ce soit mais si vous
convient vous accepté de le faire pour
moins cher puisque vous faites le film
de rachid bouchareb indigènes pour 300
euros par jour là vous êtes plus
l'artiste le mieux payé de france d'être
le moins bien payé l'associé j'espère
qu'on ira partout on commence par le
dire ce soir à la télé alors indigènes
c'est l'histoire d'un bataillon de
tirailleurs sénégalais venus libérer la
france à la fin de la seconde guerre
mondiale on les voit de l'italie aux
vosges et à la sortie qu'ils en payent
le droit de défiler sur les champs
elysées parce qu'ils étaient arabes ou
noirs
oui
je suppose que c'est que c'est à cause
de ça mais ils nous ont sorti plein de
prétexte à l'époque mais c'est sûr
qu'aujourd'hui les mieux lotis d'entre
eux ils sont dans des foyers sonacotra a
collectionné paquet pathé et c'est
inadmissible vu les sacrifices qu'ils
ont faits pour nous aujourd'hui si je
suis là devant vous à répondre à des
questions débiles c'est parce que la
grille mais c'est parce qu'ils se sont
sacrifiés parce que parce
qu'effectivement j'ai pas envie
d'oublier leurs sacrifices et à travers
ce film j'ai envie de pouvoir raconter à
mes petits frères à tous ceux qui
veulent bien l'entendre qu'on est con et
légitime ici qu'on est français
moi j'ai grandi ici j'ai vécu ici je
suis un musicien comme la bonne
intégration n'a pas l'intégration pour
toi mais moi le mot intégration n'existe
pas je te dis c'est un mot qui a été
embêté inventé par kofi yamgnane à
l'époque justifier son salaire mais non
mais c'est vrai je ne considère pas
qu'il ne faut pas qu'on ne faut pas
rentrer dans ce jeu là on est on n'a pas
à se justifier et expliquer pourquoi on
est on est légitime ici on est né ici un
point c'est tout voilà
j'avais su
et c'est bien
lagache
séparément
[Musique]
alors c'est jean-marc un truc dans cette
émission il ya de plus en plus de jeux
de jolies filles 1
bonjour madame j'aime plus que vous
faites tout depuis le début de cette
émission il regarda fait un bisou sa
part fait un pas que la gulf un gros
plan sur un jeton remercie pat flatley
viennent donc alors indigènes donc c'est
un film avec samy naceri roschdy zem
sami bouajila et notre ami jamel
debbouze tournage début janvier sortie
dans un an on en parle c'est pas une
comédie on n'est pas dans la rigolade
moi mon arrière grand père il était curé
ailleurs et est en plus en plus de pas
avoir le droit de défiler sur les champs
le deuxième bureau a fait plein de
choses un peu bizarre comme interdire
les correspondances qui empêché un peu
les les couples mixtes de se former un
il arrive à marseille libérer les
villages les les meuf elle était comme
des folles points portent l'uniforme
elle sauté dans leurs bras et eux aussi
vrai six mois et donc il s'amourache et
comme ils pouvaient sauf que c'était pas
c'était pas bien vu de 20 du point de
vue de monsieur de gaulle puis à son âme
alors toujours toujours au niveau du
cinéma c'était le fils de chimie ait mis
si l'histoire d'un cadre sup qui perd
son emploi et qui devient étalon pour la
communauté lesbienne de new york où il
cherchait sa gamme faut l'inventer ça
vraiment même temps ce prix là c'est
tant mieux pour ça hein
alors vous vous jouez le concierge
français d'un hôtel donc dragueur
gassiès lattes about 1
j'ai pas envie de parler anglais parce
que bon tout le monde ne comprend pas je
vais sur le tournage parce que spike lee
parle pas français ça tu parle pas
anglais comment vas tu parle un peu toi
au départ il va proposer le premier rôle
ouais son film va poser la question
fatidique il m'a dit les stocks anglaise
je répondu médecins d'angola
ça devrait comme ça alors c'est en vous
rendant djamel sur le tournage de ce
film que vous êtes arrivé vous arabe à
l'aéroport avec un passeport français
donc il vous en regardez quand même
temps cinq heures sa mère sa mère 16h51
hoc comme comme vieux sérieux c'est vrai
c'était un peu un peu bizarre mais bon
puisque ils sont énervés ils ont peur
j'en suis lavé tu l'avais dis ici je me
souviens on s'était vus fin septembre
2001 et tu avais dit ça va être dur pour
les arabes
même en france ouais mais c'est ça oui
ça va être dur oui c'est c'est de plus
en plus dur on sait bien c'est moi moi
franchement je
j'espère de tout mon coeur qu'on va vers
une issue mais là on vient de resigner
pour 4 piges je crois ce qui va pas
aller dans l'autre sens évident mais
mais j'ai confiance
j'ai confiance en l'avenir j'ai
confiance en mon petit frère j'ai
confiance en plein de choses que je vois
il ya de plus en plus de robots qui font
des choses que ce soit hedi slimane qui
est un arabe et médée mesdames qui est
haram aussi fâché que c'est
l'obscurantisme on sait ce que c'est
c'est céder d'abord je pense des gens
frustrés qui est qu'il souffre
fondamentalement je pense que tant pour
les combattra on n'arrivera à rien il
faut les convaincre et les etats unis
ils n'ont pas compris qu'il fallait
convaincre fages en tout cas je pense
que george bush l'a pas compris ça non
donc tant qu'on n'ira pas dans ce sens
là c'est la merde alors
le film de spike lee sortie le 17
novembre
tu sais pas non je viens d'apprendre sa
main ce que sa maman
leduc n'était même pas au courant mais
si mais si
on me dit rien c'est la dernière roue du
carrosse pour un show fait ce film
sincèrement et personne ne dit rien tu
savais pas merde c'est un succès énorme
en plus mode de foccart alors vous vous
a pas vu au cinéma depuis depuis astérix
1 et 2 2 par dieu que la ville ont fait
dix films depuis astérix
parce qu'ils avaient besoin d'acheter
des séries je suppose que je sais pas
dans chacun d'eux chacun bois ça doit
être dur comme on doit vous proposer
toutes les comédies qui passe j'imagine
non non mais c'est pas dur ccc même
gratifiant c'est dur de dire non quand
même en moi j'essaie vraiment ce que
j'ai ce que je vais faire je vais
m'amuser et toute ma vie a la chance de
faire ce métier aujourd'hui comme on dit
chez moi j'ai le choix et c'est le plus
grand des lui que je pouvais j'espère le
garder le plus longtemps possible
si je me retrouve dans des films moyens
avec des personnages difficile à
défendre et si j'y vais à reculons je
vais me décevoir je vais décevoir
j'ai pas envie de ça d'être dans cette
position je préfère monter sur celle qui
fait c'est vraiment c'est vraiment ce
que j'aime le plus au monde et et je me
suis amusé comme un fou écrire ce
spectacle met dans tous ses films
vous avez refusé jan agp ou regretté de
pas avoir fait quand même ouais j'ai
déconné j'aurais dû accepter une diana
jones quand on m'a proposé à l'époque
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
102 lieu le spectacle comment va votre
père
du très bien très très bien ça va super
bien ouais on va faire une interview mon
père ce héros à dire que la la la je
jouerai mon père enfin voilà papa aussi
tu m'excuses si tu m'écoutes je m'excuse
d'avancé comment ça va monsieur debbouze
est bien installé là je souhaite très
mal installé c'est très mal organisé
vous voulez boire quelque chose de beau
et pas l'appel marde
non c'est la première fois que vous
venez à la télévision je pose des
questions bras vous étiez quel genre de
père avec jamel tout connu charles
ingalls
oui c'est pareil
[Applaudissements]
ça vous est arrivé de lever la main sur
lui monsieur bourgi jambes alors la juge
amy la value vilana sur mon fils tu dis
j'ai levé le pied le coût de la tempête
mais la main ce genre de risque et à la
main il a manqué de quoi quand il était
petit jamais dû jamais il il a rien
hélas jamais manqué de rien bon c'est
vrai nous et il disait que au quatrième
il n'avait pas dit je suis sûr mais moi
je sais qu'il a jamais été autant
nous aurions aimé qu'il fasse quoi comme
métier djamel président de la république
et suédoise s'est passé ça vous a
surpris quand il s'est lancé dans la
comédie je l'avais je lève j'ai toujours
dit à mon fils comédienne si pour les
[ __ ] et les homosexuels nous dit ça je
suis je souhaite pas lui là vous avez
réagi comment quand vous avez vu son
spectacle monsieur debout ce jeu-là de
son spectacle oui et alors que tu est
votre réaction par beaucoup bouquet de
latapie tout ça ouais ouais et le vois
toujours les coups de poing ne voit pas
l'amour qu'il ya derrière
c'est ça qui est dommage ils vous aident
aujourd'hui djamel nom jean-louis c'est
pour ça je lui ai dit à la télévision
il est pas super si c'est pour ça donne
quand même c'est un bon fils quand même
c'est de bose mais c'est parce que tu ne
connais pas c'est pour ça vous dit ça
monsieur
je suis désolé monsieur drucker moi
d'apprendre
valet
c'est pas les relations entre deux de
vos fils jamais les moments où ça se
passe comment les rapports il sauterait
pas fraternelle j'ai dit à mon fichier
jamais le goût de la sphère travail avec
le wii s'offre à mais bien sûr mais
c'est vrai mais dès là jamais travaillé
ici pour ça sur son passeport il a
marqué piétons du paraguay mais on
compare souvent la famille debbouze et
la famille ewing pourquoi mais c'est
vrai je sois un peu comme jockey weiwei
mon fils mohamed ça serait un peu comme
gr i way et jamais elle si un peu comme
les puits de pétrole pour voir si un
plus à leur système quand vous voyez
djamen avec les plus grandes stars
françaises ça vous fait quoi monsieur
debbouze je souris
complètement malade je vois bien qu'elle
glisse dans le show-business j'essaie de
lui mais j'arrive pas à le 11 le voit
avec des stars comme par exemple qui
l'influencent mal dans le dos je veux
pas j'aime pas s'il était en face de
vous djamel vous lui diriez quoi
monsieur bush je sais que tu aimais
liardet remettez veux pas me le dire
[Musique]
nous coller de l'argent sur ses cachets
hadja mais non 80 des portions ça c'est
pas grand chose si si si si si ces
journées il ya des choses qu'il n'a
jamais osé vous dira djamel je t'aime
fabian lüthi
ajoutons que les systèmes en fait tu
mets les mecs peu papa bola et humer les
belles demeures au dessus pour le
cadrage
[Musique]
c'est vraiment un syndicat c'est la télé
c'est l'actuel système
[Applaudissements]
tu as compris ça se comprend bien
disposés à les d'accord quand il ya un
plan sur toi derrière il ya que des
belles mais voilà c'est magnifique non
je suis battu pour être producteur de
télé c'est vrai que c'est facile on
pouvait faire catherine barma comme
métier dans la vie
ah non c'est impossible elle est unique
à ce jour aux jeux la connaît depuis
maintenant bientôt cinq ans même +11
jamais jamais déçu
c'est une professionnelle moi ça fait 20
ans que tu la connais ouais 20 ans qui
travaille avec elle alors mais ça va
bien tu content très content tu comptes
soit je vais continuer encore 20 ans
c'est rien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
très bien bonsoir
on était amusant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui comme à la maison là il ya les
meubles là où je les avais laissés alors
vous êtes ici tous les deux pour angel a
le nouveau film de luc besson
un film dont la sortie est entourée du
plus grand mystère
à commencer par l'actrice principale
alors on avait parlé de milla jovovich
en avait parlé de sara forestier
d'angelina jolie d'uma thurman et c'est
vous rie rasmussen qui apparaissait à
l'écran voilà non pas du tout un
traducteur d'avancé en 3 mois 4 way
attend c'est pour toi c'est un mec ça
fait trois fois qu'il appelle situait
alors
ouais ça abricots je comprends pas assez
cuit ouais je t'invite à mon mariage
moi je dois kamel qui calait le groupe i
à la tournée a oui il était dans la
figuration d'indigènes ben voilà c'est
pas comme on les aime bien ce genre de
fumée qui tape ans en bac pour noter la
mine de rien à [ __ ] son prénom mais
super tihange coupe ce couple ça suffit
là parce qu il appelait déjà trois fois
pendant l'émission
voilà la donne et on le sait bien
alors on s'occupe de vous rieu car andy
rihs yeux les français c'est bien
évidemment vous êtes danoise
effectivement est né le 14 février 1978
à copenhague famille nombreuse neuf
frères et soeurs est une femme complète
à ce we see mannequin d'abord un mètre
78 86 61 88
vous comprendrez chiffres sont exacts
ces chips lays bien varié et en vous
voyant dans les coulisses d'un défilé
yves saint laurent collection automne
hiver 2001 2002 tom ford grand homme
ford vous a remarqué et a décidé que
vous deviendrez l'image de marque de
gucci voilà ensuite je vais incarner
absolue de rochas organza de givenchy
grande carrière de mannequin actrice
dans femme fatale de brian de palma mais
aussi cinéaste je vous ai fait une école
de cinéma vous allez réaliser des courts
métrages dont l'un a été sélectionné
dans la compétition officielle à cannes
en 2004 voilà donc d'une femme complète
[Applaudissements]
ouais il manque selon m servat triste
c'est bien d'être salvatrice
oui ça va certes 16 vraiment la donne
des cours de français on a fait ça en
famille on a préféré garder leurs
meilleurs a dépeinte surprise mais à la
fin un travail de fou parce qu'il a
trois mâts parlait pas vraiment un mot
de français
ma mère j'avais de 20 ans qu'elle est
ici rogers pourtant elle dira toujours
fortement
comment elle est alors djamel à la brède
b car ça va juliette oui
le chipeau juliette la commune
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est incroyable
jean ça c'est pas de l'eau juliette tu
m'as sauvé la vie alors je lâche plus
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qui se passe encore mais
comment savoir si dans les landes et
patricia belle quand elle est alors
comment l'aiba là j'ai fait sans gérer
tout ça j'ai expliqué tout ce qu'avait
fait dans sa vie tout mais comment elle
est dans la vie que le moment j'ai pris
un vrai qu'ils font à tourner avec cette
fille gérons qu'on se connaissait pas
voilà voilà
c'est pour ça tu coupera à gagner de
façon on n'est pas en direct là tu peux
couper parce que 1 600 directs
maintenant parce qu'elle est surprenante
voisins elle parle des trucs comme ça
sans prévenir personne là il ya un vrai
que l'eau tu vois un peu débordés parce
que la tepa concentre donc on est armé
mais c'est vrai que non
on se connaissait pas forcément elle
avait à la neil la fiche technique
moi je l'avais page d'accueil je la
connaissais pas le connaissait plus que
je la connaissais et puis elle n'était
pas été signés impressionner ni par lui
que ni par nous on arrive à 15 à fond à
chaque fois qu'on débarque sur un
plateau momo karine vif
hichem la néo zélandaise ouais ok j'ai
viré son polar sans françois paul et les
autres n était pas du tout impressionnée
elle s'est pas démonté elle a travaillé
son texte on a fait des répétitions
enfin ça c'était un briquet qu'est ce
que tu veux tu dire de plus il ne
parlait pas français elle a fait un film
tourné en français avec luc besson avec
dédé des robots qui parle pas assez bien
cinq français traduit et qui parle très
vite aussi alors l'autre acteur du
nouveau film de luc besson c'est jamel
debbouze
alors on dit toujours djamel que vous
n'avez pas fait de film depuis astérix
fatigue les clefs de bagnole quand même
et oui les clefs de bagnole bien sûr qui
est fou un carton par l'upa monumentale
mais il
[Applaudissements]
alors au départ besson voulait bosser
avec vous mais vous voulez vous confié à
gérard pire elle soit graphique
minecraft dit tu arrives pas non plus
les critiques et toi tu as dit non tu as
dis moi où cb sens où c'est rien ça
besson c'est facile a lancé son site
besson qui rattrape si j'aime beaucoup
ce mec j'ai rien contre du péras micra
dig s ur mais mais j'avais envie de
travailler avec besson et comme je fais
les choses que par envie arêtes du 28e
déconcentrait ce qui me pousse les
couilles dépendons de la vie oui donc
les 110 que vous lui avez donné envie de
refaire du cinéma jamel j'ai été très
touchée comme l'a dit mais
moi j'avais envie de bosser avec lui
c'est son univers qui m'intéressent j'ai
vu le dernier combat j'ai vu une équipe
tu as et j'aime bien son cinéma que
j'avais envie de travailler avec l'udc
voilà alors dans le film vous êtes un
mythomane qui s'est mis dans la merde à
force de mythomanie un type qui sait
même pas qui a trop menti à tout le
monde et à lui même et qui veut se
suicider et au moment où il va se
suicider arrive un ange une folle
furieuse une cinglée arrêts alors le
pitch est l'histoire de quelqu'un qui
s'aiment pas en fait c'est ça mais qu'il
va apprendre à s'aimer
bah ouais c'est cesse et c'était facile
à jouer ça parce qu'on a tous un peu ça
on nous croit si on a tous un moment
donné c'est tout se trouvait pourri
bidon maze
alors là les périodes sont plus ou moins
longues et en fonction des des gens que
qui t'aime ou non tu t'en sors mais
quand y'a pas d'amour autour de toi
c'est sorti dans la merde et ce sans
faire de parallèle il ni de lien avec ce
qui se passe en banlieue c'est la
personne qui s'intéresse à ces gamins
donc forcément sont livrés à eux mêmes
ils réagissent comme ils ont envie de
réagir est là elle m'a regardé dans les
yeux elle m'a dit que j'étais très
intéressant que j'étais beau qu'elle
l'aimait et
[Applaudissements]
surtout c'est apprendre à s'aimer pour
aimer les autres en fait une phrase très
touchante dans le film c'est quand vous
dites
pour la première fois j'ai envie de dire
tout ce que je ressens c'est beau
l'amour
si on était chez pas sur l'occasion de
le faire souvent ce à dire véritablement
ce qu'on ressent c'est déjà arrivé et
huawei a lâché tu as de la chance mais
moi plus de plus en plus là j'ai
vraiment c'est un vrai qui frappe la
nature sans quoi la là j'aime bien tout
ce qui se passe autour de cette table
comment je me sens bien ma parole est ce
qui se passe à 7 après avoir saisi ce
que j'aime bien la proximité la
féminitude le troisième personnage du
film c'est paris le paris des cartes
postales pour lexandre 3 la tour eiffel
le sacré-coeur le pont-des-arts très
très bien filmé en noir et blanc
c'est sur ce qui est génial c'est comme
toi je regarde si j'ai pas eu de textos
de quelques gamelles alors j'ai reçu un
texto de mon neveu qui me dit voici ma
pleuré en voyant l'extrait du film il
m'a dit qu'il aimait pas quand on était
triste et il a trois pigeons wassim si
du cinéma eva photo il a la patate
[Applaudissements]
je kiffe en skiff mais moi j'ai de la
chance d'avoir des gens qui m'aiment je
te jure c'est vrai il est des trésors
tout tu peux monter descendre faire des
millions d'entrées être le meilleur
joueur de foot du monde avec le plus
grand des et des philosophes et la plus
belle des femmes s'est aperçu le petit
qui fait qu'ils t'aiment qui te le dis
c'était quoi merde t'es une merde
[Applaudissements]
voilà donc pour tourner un pari sans
voiture sans bateau il fallait tourner
deux bonnes heures le week-end aux
matinées home and away à 4h du mat et
voir comment tu faisais pas je te remets
pas c'était pendant l'été mais c'est
vrai qu'il de tourner à paris
moi j'adore paris l'équipe ce qui
aperçoit elle est l'élue mi-août sont
vides moi je chez la plus belle ville du
monde tu l'apprends pleine quête l'été
parce que véritablement tu la vois là tu
vois les pavés tu voi et les monuments
qui surtout ce qu'il a montré pour
lexandre 3 le pont bir hakeim ça c'est
déjà choisi vraiment les havrais en
écosse endroit magique
hu est déjà tombé sur un match comme ça
dans ta vie le 18 juin 75
la mairie va pas lâcher de plus je vais
faire quoi maintenant montrant passé 20
mois ouais ouais
besson l'a déjà produit un court métrage
à vous non oui assez avec euros par son
société qui fait produire les jeunes
talents et moi j'ai fait une commettra
chez burger que j'avais écrit c'est le
laki direct mercan après j'ai fait des
autres courts métrages m'a demandé de
faire actrice seulement jeudi vient bien
sûr avec plaisir si c'est le seul que je
fais de ma vie je suis contente et
maintenant la prochaine j'espère c'est
une vraie artiste elle des signes elle
pointe la photo aussi fait des photos
des peintures des dessins et j'arrive
des devoirs comme tu veux voir sur la
couverture de livre que c'est ce qu'on a
on peut utiliser alors je dessinais avec
du café et des confitures des sucres
poêlé
miel si vous voulez oui où je peux vous
faire une belle et votre fiancée est à
paris en ce moment bon c'est quand c'est
oui
s'il y avait les pépettes les dettes
s'est campé dette
c'est elle que les filles non moins pas
du tout si tu avais dit ttp des mots
mais moi je ne sais pas si tu voulais
que tu laisses tranquille c'est sa
maison d'hôtes à neige elle m'a dit je
ne sais pas trop qui pendant tout le
tournage et les laisser tranquille je
pensais qu'elle était peut-être tessier
de la pêche au gdc ya du flore
entreprises comme je sais qu'il fait des
trucs avec du miel et de la confiture
j'étais comme ça exige rien à faire je
pensais qu'elle aimait que les meufs
j'aimais bien quant à miss l'arabe
l'aller petit string jesse j'ai tenté un
truc
ok ma carrière là alors jamais le moment
où il ya eu les émeutes dans les
banlieues j'ai demandé de venir sur le
sur le plateau de tout le monde en parle
pour vous exprimer pour en parler pour
témoigner et kader aoun et vous m'avez
répondu on a fait un spectacle ça oui ça
fait 20 ans qu'on en parlerait faire ddd
avec tout le respect que j'ai pour toi
j'adore venir ici c'est vrai mais tu as
eu raison parce qu'on a passé les
extraits du spectacle et c'était très
pertinent et tout le monde a été
d'accord avec ça alors merci d'un merci
parce que je sais c'est vrai
effectivement ça fait moi ça fait 20 ans
que je monte sur scène que je passe des
associations l'association pour gueuler
à qui vous veut bien entendre qu' il y a
des problèmes chez nous mais j'étais
très surpris de voir à quel point ça
avait surpris les gens c'est vrai ça
m'avait serais étonné de voir à quel
point les gens et aimé pouvoir n'est
content de ce qui s'est passé
tout a brûlé ouais bien sûr tout cas
brûler des gens qui souffrent personne
ne les entends vrai le climat il un peu
bizarre en ce moment je trouve s'est
fait insulter par finkielkraut est
touchée que la dernière fois que
juliette est venu ici finkielkraut l'a
fait pleurer c'est pas vrai c'est
quelqu'un qui a fait pleurer je me
défoncerai membres à céret
quitte à faible revenu grands pas voir
de quel bois je me chauffe eau mais
normalement je devrais venir
ouais mais est ce que c'est vraiment à
cause de lui c'est pas le mec il trouve
que l'équipe de france c'est la honte
parce qu'elle est trop black black black
ils voulaient casser quelques que des
barges partout alors peut-être non
seulement on n'aurait même pas vaincu ce
qui m'étonne c'est le pc c'est vraiment
il ya des cons laisse passer pas mal de
choses quand même tu vois je te jure ça
m'a rappelé 1955 mois le le le le
couvre-feu
c'est ça rassemble au début de la guerre
d'algérie tout ça c'est des vrais
signaux forts c'est c'est un bourgeois
qui arrivent avec des caméras et qui
regardent des petits robots
accompagnement qui leur dit je vais vous
nettoyer au kärcher bande de racailles
c'est tournez manège pour moi il était
penché sur le sens du mot banlieue un
peuple épris zab la racaille
c'est ça que ce n'est rien dictionnaire
ses banlieues ces lieux de bannissement
fait de bannissement jusqu'où alors non
peuple méprisable on va vous mettre dans
un lieu banni re donner ça que ça veut
dire et c'est des mecs qui nicolas
sarkozy vraiment j'ai rien à [ __ ] en
lui d'ailleurs nicolas et quand monsieur
nicolas sarkozy si vous m'écoutez
beau boulot très très beau boulot c'est
sûr et certain
c'est comme ça qu'il ya huit ans les
gens parce que tu leur dis quand même le
karcher c'est fait pour nettoyer la
merde si tu as entendu parler et c'est
pour nettoyer la merde dont il considère
que les gens qui habitent en banlieue
c'est de la merde c'est ça qu'on entends
tu vois il est la critique critiqué mme
intermédiation des ghettos les ghettos
de pauvres ils créent des ghettos de
riches le mec à neuilly c'est sa vie on
est d'accord il ya que 2 % de logements
sociaux devrait y en avoir 20 alors le
mec qui défend nos lois il est déjà hors
la loi
géré par ggg je le trouve marrant je le
trouve sympa un mois ce mec je trouve
juste qu'il est là pouf
tu as dit c'est très triste pour les
gens qui ont pris des crédits pour
acheter des fiat panda mais je suis
content qu'il se passe quelque chose
mais attends chez toi tu te rends compte
mais jacques chirac il est venu parler
rai télévision se commettant il faut
pour un rendez vous avec chirac il faut
d une année bissextile
maintenant c'est la dernière fois ici on
a bien quelques phrases avec guy bedos
sont donc c'est de la souffrance après
bien sûr qu'on brûle les bagnoles des
mecs et ils payent ces personnes pas
d'accord avec ça mais on crie quand on a
mal on crie ou on pleure et on crie en
fait mal quand on a mal est vraiment
fort a été la chaîne et si effectivement
il ya un mec qui lance dakar cheikh des
mots non mais qui ont fait ça sont eux
ces jeux mal moi j'entends que je vois
des gens qui ont mal et ça me fait mal
mais environ mal
moi quand je l'aï entendu dire la
télévision qu' effectivement français
françaises il ya des discriminations
dans ce pays ça marche toujours je me
suis dit tiens ça fait plaisir et encore
moins qui s'en aperçoit ils arrivent ils
débarquent on a la pression
et puis derrière il nous propose des
solutions qui sont tout sauf des
solutions nous avec mon gouvernement
travaillons sur la question n'est pour
l'instant à vous donnera une réponse
ultérieurement
c'est toi qui dis y'a pas que il ya
juste en face de nous des gens qui
n'arrêtent pas d'occulter le fait que au
soufre et c'est vrai que l'ambiance elle
un peu pourri en ce moment ça pue un peu
je sais pas si tu as remarqué comment
c'est en train de tuer là je peux citer
d'une manière générale pour pas d'accord
trouve ça un peu plus a appelé ceux qui
sont d'accord faut qu'on ne s'appuie pas
reprend nicolas sarkozy
c'étaient les écoutes s'appuyant
cependant il faut mettre du musée en
gouvernementale alors vous dites jamais
on vous dit que vous êtes contre le mot
intégration parce que vous dites qu'il
n'ya pas besoin d'être internet vous
êtes français donc elle a bien sûr
besoin de vous intégrer et fo ont appelé
next web intégré vous êtes français
voilà et visitent ces gosses sont mal et
les seules personnes qui leur tendent la
main viennent des mosquées les mecs qui
viennent les voir
il leur propose de faire des ronds
rouges c'est ce qu'on appelle des
sorties à strasbourg pour aller prêcher
lille marcq en baroeul en italie pour
prêcher la bonne parole
alors il y en a qui sont sincères et qui
ont véritablement la fois et puis dans
tout ça tu as des bâtards qui profitent
de la situation
pcsi et s'est enfoncé ses gosses dans
l'obscurantisme et signe de la
responsabilité de la france que de leur
proposer des idées des d'ouvrir leur
école c'est une galère de rentrer à
sciences po et à l'ena comment c'est
possible si c'est une galère de trouver
du taf
comment c'est possible ça c'est une
galère de trouver du taf alors bien sûr
ils ont trouvé il ya des solutions aux
baisse les impôts des riches mais c'est
pas la peine moi je devrais être content
je suis riche
j'en ai rien à [ __ ] je te ferai pas
comme ça qu'on va réussir à alors rendre
service à eux une solution c'est d'aller
voter et pour aller voter faut d'abord
s'inscrire c'est ça pour s'inscrire faut
se dépêcher parce qu'en fait on peut pas
s'inscrire en 2006 faut s'inscrire avant
la fin du mois de décembre
ouais et puis il faut cesser plus
efficace que de brûler des fiat pente à
s'organiser aller voter c'est un c'est
c'est la seule manière de pouvoir leur
dire qu'on n'est pas d'accord et de se
battre pour leur peau pour nos propres
idées
faut arrêter de créer des clans c'est
juste ça faut arrêter de de faire croire
à la france entière qu'on ait des
voleurs des bandits citoyens actifs la
fin n'a rien à [ __ ] de ce que je
raconte peut-être lent mais un citoyen
actif tu venais pas tiens le voilà
regarde le citoyen
[Applaudissements]
car monsieur
mais c'est toi les actifs
[Applaudissements]
on
commence pour accepter c'est la rentrée
djabel vaut mieux pas essayé moi il m'a
planté 3 l'apport du jour luc besson le
jo il m'a dit alors c'était bien le
dîner que jamais qui n'est pas venu me
dit mais moi il n'est pas venu au mien
parce qu'il a dit qu'il ya d'inactifs la
promotion d'angela le collectif la
rhumerie juliette bientôt l'épitaphe
comment ça va un citoyen actif
ça va ça va aller voter à la fois la
voûte étoilée rappelle michael évident
que malone répondeur téléphonique lui il
me demande de me rappeler lost island tu
peux enlever un peu ta casquette parce
que je te vois pas là ça va lâcher avant
l'accord je suis pas allé chez le
coiffeur
assez pour s'agisse d'un sultan avec le
collectif la queue chez thibault alors
jusqu'à les faire
ben jusqu'à la fin du mois de décembre
l'abonnement et après on fait ça
recommence en septembre prochain jusqu'à
décembre jusqu'à décembre
ça serait que de septembre ne demande
pas comment ça fonctionne voir quand je
suis pas je peux au fait de tout ça
c'est vraiment là on sait que ça
fonctionne comme ça d'ailleurs nous ont
lâchés au dernier moment se ressemblent
pour ça que le truc c'est monter enfin
l'appel on a eu deux semaines on peut
pas appeler tous les médias et pour les
allées quoi ce qui ce qui fait un peu
qu'on a une légitimité pour aller dire
aux gens un peu aussi à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui
s'il vous plaît allez vous inscrire et
pierre agissez fédéraux nous et ainsi de
suite
c'est justement fait déjà la base un
travail de fois aidé à sausheim des
associe aussi il faut absolument tout et
tout le monde prenne conscience qu'il
fallait chercher sa carte d'électeur
banlieue pas blonde beaulieu arrêter de
créer des clans et nous nous expliquer
que ces gens là se comporte mal ces gens
là c'est nous ces gens là c'est vous
c'est toute la france c'est se tirer une
balle dans le pied que que de ghettoïser
que de sectoriser comme ça la france est
pas possible de commissions la vérité la
réconciliation non et ça on attend en
afrique du sud en afrique ici de pérouse
en français c'est des gens qu'il va
trois firmes ayant voté une loi pour
qu'on positive l'action coloniale c'est
si on va pas au fond de ce qui s'est
passé et de refermer de de revenir à la
mémoire de ce qui s'est passé que les
gens parlent et c'est ce qu'ils soient
déjà entendu et qu'on enregistre les
toutes les histoires à ce moment-là ça
changerait déjà là la situation dans les
mentalités session si on n'a pas dans
les dents les générations d'avant les
générations qui viennent à présent
toujours mal
c'est un cancer façon la france a un peu
enfin moi je le savais me fasse des
remarques et encore un peu plus
dernièrement quoi la france a un peu
peur de regarder son passé dans les yeux
grands appartements on a colonisé des
gens il ya un moment donné où on a
toutes les valeurs de démocratie tout ça
on les a oubliés quoi un mot donné je
pense que je pense que ces gens qui
aujourd'hui sont un peu désoeuvrés façon
je pense que si on leur explique qu'en
fait c'est la france qui nous a fait
nous sommes français qu'il ya une vraie
histoire autour de ça déjà je pense que
ça m'arrivait une confusion une
conscience civique et ainsi de suite
donc c'est un mouvement pour la vraie
liberté la vraie égalité et la vraie
fraternité c'est ça attention ça c'est
sympa comme slogan c'est bien comme on
n'a pas envie de penser que c'est
utopique vraiment y croire parce que moi
je crois en mon pays c'est pas possible
ça possible qu'on nous explique matin
midi et soir qu'on n'est pas les
bienvenus ce pas possible de gens et de
jeunes quoi oublier qu'on n'a pas de
chance content d'être en france mais
aussi à plein de choses qui me rassure
je pense que pour parler franchement
d'envoyer les gens s'inscrire et voter
prochainement
c'est sûr qu'en ce moment si les plus
jeunes nous voyais pratique et ça
comment l'automatisme je pense qu'à long
terme se passera pas comme quoi je crois
tu me la faut voir sur le long terme
maintenant c'est sûr et puis ça peut
susciter des vocations aussi c'est très
bien j'ai prise de conscience citoyenne
la tutelle avant ça génial même placé
pour pouvoir dire ce qui manque en
banlieue que ce soit d'un point de vue
social pratiques ou autre c'est quand
les premiers protagonistes vers les gens
qui vivent quoi il ya des gens qui vont
pas voter parce que d'après ils n'ont
pas le poids mais le point ils voient
tous ne sais pas si c'est ça
moi-même je n'ai jamais voté donc qui
n'est jamais vainqueur le vin je vais
chercher ma carte à tous rendez vous en
faites en face de la mairie de clichy
sous bois
voilà il ya une journée c'est le 20
décembre à 14 heures voilà pour en garde
organisé une marche
enfin c'est le truc symbolique bien que
ça va ouais je me suis plus le 20
décembre la mairie pour s'inscrire
ouais ouais voilà c'est ça prenait
conscience une voix égale une voix ouais
surtout ne vous garez pas aller chez ce
jour là est ce que le citoyen actif
reste avec nous la confiance est revenue
très bien via mail anti porter chinois
de toi
[Musique]
jamais shabelle où tu es prêt pollentier
portrait chinois
[Applaudissements]
jamal dati jamal ça soit une heure y'a
pas de couilles reviendra plus les
jardins une heure je suis désolé je
voulais pas le faire au départ je le
fais dissidente et portrait chinois
d'accord joey starr mais là quand même
pour le coup tu voyais pas les put alors
ce qu'ils faisaient
et aussi il disait des blagues racistes
ça fait trois jours qu'il cherche
juliette elle m'a dit [ __ ] c'est
dégueulasse
j'avais lutté près ça va heureusement
fait d'ici mais jamel a beau être venu
avec une armée de [ __ ] il ne manque
que lorsqu'il fait il fait début des
petites femelles août à début du match
un peu la gueule c'est pas grave c'est
juste muriel que je voulais pas visées
et pris un peu la convention opposition
et marianne et on peut tout faire
maintenant tu bouges plus une oreille
bracelets maintenant est ce que tu sais
que ta chaussure droite c'est fait
exprès ou pas oublier les tickets de
tickets ça s'appelle le style ça
s'appelle du vol
djamel tu sais que les parents de muriel
jeux vendus chaussures aujourd'hui elle
est au cour des prés ouais si c'était un
gros mot attends je vais juste vérifier
un truc
on n'y arrivera jamais il est aumônier à
quand un pape le pinard à ces mecs de
banlieue c'était ça n'aurait chercheurs
[Applaudissements]
les ménages belges étaient trop coûteux
c'est très bien vas-y tu t'étais un gros
mot sa mère lipopette c'était une guerre
une guerre si j'étais une guerre voilà
un coup je serai avec la guerre contre
les pointes sèches et les cheveux
cassants
c'était un accident
la coupe du monde derrière la dernière
coupe du monde de la nature c'était un
dictateur juge était un dictateur
charlie chaplin
j'étais à bout et j'étais un gorille le
bruit qui court que je suis pas régulier
de billups nantes indret je sais pas moi
c'est après l'émission donnée au site
était un assassin zinédine zidane sans
exception tu es d une trahison
mon bras droit ce salon avec toute ma
confiance
c'était un meuble un canapé convertible
pour le convertir à l'islam
tiens tu t'étais un supplice voté chirac
en 2002 c'est un supplice
c'était un légume chirac j'ai pas mieux
[Applaudissements]
si tt à fait peur j'étais un terroriste
carlos papayou papayou l'ailé c'était un
saint maclou pour une saint michel pour
l'heure il été un supplice
je recommence
j'ai été un supplice reste gros coup
[Applaudissements]
sa quête de repères ça incroyable qui
tue pas envie de te taper devant tout le
monde tu fais des c'est quoi toi tu
rigoles comme un conte de ses blagues
c'est pour ça qu'il y va aussi après des
regards il surenchérit arrêt non plus si
des white spirit revanche pas du feu non
mes sens en regarde pas qu'est ce que
c'est ça je peux je ne peux pas rester
comme ça c'est pas possible il est
castro dans ton sur ton plateau plus ça
y est j'ai attrapé la crève bâtiment tôt
pour déjà mais pas une petite culotte
pour endurer star
petit et chats vas-y vas-y vas-y pardon
si tu étais un animal mon frère mon beau
[Rires]
l'importateur demande apple n'arrive pas
tu sais pourquoi parce que gillett elle
a pas beaucoup dormi si c'était un impôt
mon père et si c'était une ordure
le père noël ouais tu m'as il m'a oublié
- dernière rien ramené j'ai commandé un
autre à 4
[Rires]
[Musique]
ça fait plaisir votre casquette
interview
l'autre était pas mieux non ça dépend
des invités oui mais c'est plus facile
de vivre ait jamais teva non ça ne
m'intéresse pas ah oui désolé
jamel est ici ce soir pour une double
actualité est d'abord le jamel comedy
club sur canal+
et puis le film indigènes et quand je
pense qu'on dit que les arabes sont
feignants c'est énorme ce que vous
faites en une année c'est à dire celui
travail d'arabe voilà du bon tour et là
alors jamel comedy club très beau titre
d'abord très facile très simple on le
doit qu'à deraa où une paix des braves
aux cadors tiens j'en profite pour
remercier le cas l'air le plus cliqué
pour cette émission depuis quatre ans
voilà aussi à présent c'est à lui qu'a
l'air
alors jamais le comedy club au titre
émission diffusée tous les samedis à 20h
sur canal+ à partir du 15 juillet une
émission dans laquelle vous donner leur
chance à de nouveaux comiques
spécialisée dans le stand-up exact c'est
comme le petit théâtre de bouvard mais
on n'en drôle quoi en plus funky on dira
la voilà qui fait la toupie passé sur
canal c'est bien cette chaîne canal
disons que c'est une chaîne qui permet
de qui laisse la place
ah ouais non c'est sûr que moi
d'ailleurs je remercie canal+ pour plein
de trucs vraiment un
là on a été les voir avec ce concept ils
ont dit oui tout de suite j'avoue que ça
fait plaisir d'être avec des gens comme
ça voilà moi c'est une aventure humaine
formidable et c'est un coach qui est
arrivé
merci alors le pitch de cette émission
de dire qu'elle est basée sur le stand
up un micro quatre artistes par émission
qui viennent faire cinq minutes de
discours moi c'est vrai que c'est c'est
kader qui va montrer cette forme
scénique je connaissais pas le stand-up
avant qu'il en parle j'ai découvert
richard pryor eddie murphy dave
chappelle c'est des mecs qui qui qui
sont dans le plus simple appareil
ils arrivent ils ont un micro à la main
et il te racontent ce qu'ils ont fait la
veille c'est incroyable il donne
l'impression que c'est que tout le monde
peut le faire en fait c'est ça c'est
comme quand tu vois zinedine zidane dans
une surface de réparation tu as
l'impression que tout le monde peut
faire la roulette 1 tu pourrais pas
faire c'est plus une prise de parole en
fait que des pitreries quoi c'est
vraiment un discours quoi c'est une
étude sociologique cette émission ouais
tu vas voir ça réglait way
[Musique]
pourquoi prendre et c'est le cas d'andré
way et l'europe
cette mission vous devez successivement
dire du bien de laurent gerra et du mal
du mal de zinédine zidane à malvesi
lydie et du bien géorgien et eu bien du
mal de zinedine zidane oui et dire du
bien que laurent gerra on vas tu veux
mais pourquoi pas manger du porc
[Musique]
tourné avec moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est la galère
[Applaudissements]
k
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah la la
à
excusez nous de vous avoir dérangé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
rien que ce champagne étaient payés avec
l'argent de leurs redevances et je leur
en ai pensé pour tous les intermittents
qui n'ont pas pu l'en 67 eur
[Musique]
m
je
[Musique]
car le
carlos est
m
[Applaudissements]
c'est gentil hein c'est gentil merci
monsieur de boules et excusez-moi de
vous avoir dérangé
j'apprécie
[Applaudissements]
les corrections de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous mettez un
pouce bleus